people say the little man can't get
ahead it's harder than ever in America
today inflation the housing market the
guy in the White House and what I found
is you can get ahead in America today if
you just follow a really simple
controversial Upstream path but most
people want to make it more complicated
they think they're smarter than that
there's Pride there's fear there's greed
and then people calling the show at 60
going I'm screwed what do I do so that
in the simplest terms would be your
advice to make any viewer watching right
now A Millionaire yeah if you just
follow these principles you will get
there and you have the things on the
other side I said this is going to be
jarring this is not going to be what you
want to hear George welcome back to the
iced coffee hour really happy that
you're here our last episode I think is
it like 600,000 everybody loved it
everyone wanted to follow hot takes we
had a great time thank you for your
generosity and uh I I think it was a fun
conversation I think what's really
interesting that people really
appreciate it is that we have very
different views on debt on credit cards
on finances you have your way I have my
way and we're able to have a good
conversation about it it and I think
people really like that so we're going
to dive even further into that because
you made a whole book about how bad
credit cards are and how you should
never use them and I was reading through
it and we have some disagreements that
we probably have to Hash can I just say
Graham let me remind you I am on the
back of the book that you on the back of
the book and here's what Graham had to
say George dives into Financial topics
that should be required learning for
absolutely everyone whether you're just
starting or on your path of Financial
Freedom this book has every tidbit to
help optimize every dollar sign
St real estate inv YouTube personality
so first of all thank you for ending it
that means a lot that you put your stamp
of approval on it even though we don't
agree on all things finances but exactly
we have a very mutual uh Mutual
respectful relationship and it's been so
great getting to know you guys over the
years we're going to dive into it today
you said chapter 3 in your book was the
strongest argument against debt that you
think you've ever heard against credit
cards against credit cards that you've
ever heard in the credit cards chapter
I'm just going to recite some of the
things that you said in this chapter so
people get an idea of what you said okay
this like a court of law he's like I'm
going to use your own words against you
now you claim these credit card
companies lure you in using heavy metal
cards to impress your friends
congratulations you've been approved as
though it's a good thing they say we are
pleased to announce we have increased
your credit limit they give you rewards
they give you sign up bonuses they give
you discounts they give you exclusive
lounge access you say statistically 80%
of people reading this have a credit
card so 80% of you viewers have a credit
card conducted by ramsy Solutions this
guy knows his sources and you also said
49% of people can't pay off their
monthly credit card bill in 2023 there
is an outstanding debt of credit cards
of over $ trillion spread over 55
million households with each household
balance averaging over $14,000 and an
average interest rate of 22% those are
all facts those are none of my real
opinions but yes those are all that's
all accurate that's in the book after
reading that just as a bystander I think
it's interesting because I never put the
two and two together until you wrote
that the way credit
cards frame their language of saying
congratulations you've been approved
this is a great thing look at what we
just did I do think that's interest I
mean that's marketing at the end of the
day yeah they want to frame it as a good
thing and it can be it can be a good
thing depending on the credit card that
you get approved for well I think it's
more about the emotional validation we
get from like they're giving me more
credit limit like what does that really
mean they're giving me more access to
debt now if that's the game you want to
play that's fine but for most people
when you ask them what their financial
goals are they would say well to get out
of debt which is such a hilarious
contradiction that for the average
consumer their singular goal is to get
out of debt and they're getting excited
when they have access to more debt and
they think it's winning because that's
the scoreboard we've created in America
you think though that could be a
selection bias that the people who are
getting into personal finance step
number one for the for a lot of those
people who are just starting is debt get
out of the debt well we tell them to
succeed in America financially you got
to have a good credit score and so how
do you do that well people will open a
credit card and they swipe the card
going into debt even temporarily at the
heart of it I just think people aren't
winning as much as they think they are
and the credit card companies love when
people think they're winning so do you
think this is something though where if
you're good at it you could win yes but
that's kind of like saying if you're
good at gambling you should Gamble and
everyone goes like well I I think I'm
good I won that one time and so they
sort of self- Select themselves and go
like I'm going to be the guy who does it
well I think it's different I think if
you're good at card counting so if
you're good at being a winning player
then I think that's different because
the game isn't set to Def to defeat you
in credit cards and stuff like that like
sure a lot of people do end up losing
money but that every tool that you need
to get ahead is in the system right see
like the way the way I think about it
Define getting ahead that's really what
it comes down to it could be similar to
starting a business let's just say
because you say it's money loing
proposition while starting a business is
money losing for a lot of people but
some succeed so couldn't it be the same
way
if you know what you're doing and you're
successful at it you can do really well
you can make a lot of money in both a
business and with credit cards yeah I
mean some people do game the system um
and so I talk about that at at what cost
does that come because it comes at a
cost credit card companies are not
nonprofit Charities they're not just
giving away money and so I talk about
where the money actually comes from that
turns into rewards and cash back and
points and all that and as I got into it
like it's just not pretty it's not my
opinion of like well it comes from this
group over here there's multiple studies
from the Federal Reserve that are now
showing like oh it's the people who are
uneducated
lowincome suffering the most that are
funding this whole program and it's not
a moral thing to say you're a bad person
if you get cash back it's not that at
all but it doesn't make me feel like I'm
winning when I'm that's how the system
works it's just kind of gross and so if
I can opt out of it by using debit and
cash I'm opting out of it and that's
just one reason on top of many to not
use the credit card it's interesting you
turn it into a moral argument because
I've never seen it that way if you could
explain where that money is coming from
and who's receiving the money that' be
great like an exact oh yeah well the FED
found that $15 billion moves from the
poor uneducated lower income to the
higher educated wealthy and there's
billions and billions of dollars that
gets moved in that way and it's all
stemming from the credit card companies
and a lot of people say well George
credit card compan the money I'm getting
in my cash back is from transaction fees
it's from The Interchange The
Interchange that's what they're saying
but I actually looked at the data and
capital one has their earnings report
right there online for anyone to go
check out and it turns out it was like
75% of the earnings from Capital 1's
credit card Revenue came from interest
not from now that's Capital One what
about American Express well American
Express is different they have a
different business model and you know
that and so where does most of their
money come from it comes from charging
the highest possible transaction fee in
the industry 3 and a half% to businesses
when you swipe that American Express so
that's why a lot of small businesses go
we don't take AMX because we're not
going to stomach that fee and pass it on
to the consumer and so either way it's
not pretty AMX is a different story
because of their business model you know
these charge cards you you have to pay
them off at the end of the month and so
it's a different model but for most
people the rewards cards they're it's
coming mostly from interest and fees
which is coming from people who can't
pay it off yeah your Capital One example
I do think makes sense because Capital
One generally besides the Venture X
business card which pretty good sign
up fantastic that would be hilarious if
this was brought to you by Capital One
but no uh Capital One usually is seen as
like a beginner credit card where they
really just send out Mass mailers to
just about anybody so it would make
sense that for them their business model
would be heavily Reliant to people just
carrying a balance because they don't
know any better yeah and so the I I was
trying to just go at it from a research
standpoint versus like here's how I feel
cuz I really truly like I don't think
anyone's a bad person for using a credit
card or that it's wrong to get cash back
I just think it's an interesting angle
for people who are already kind of on
the fence to go like you're right I'm
going to opt out and truthfully people
have reached out to me going I didn't
know that this is the case and it
finally made me cut up the card and now
I feel more free than ever and I'm
Building Wealth faster do you think
credit card companies are immoral I
think a company is amoral in a sense I
think the people involved in it that are
at the top and the way they're making
money um I don't think it's the right
way to make money I think there there's
you can serve people in a way and run a
business in such a way that it helps a
lot of people I don't think causing
people to go into debt is a worthwhile
business to be in and you know there's a
lot of companies that make billions of
dollars you know would we say Sally May
is is a moral company or are they evil
uh as a company they're just a company
but the things they do in order to
attract business we would say is immoral
like paying financial aid counselors and
putting them on cruises and order to
pitch Sally May products that's pretty
gross putting them in call centers and
making them think they're talking to a
financial aid counselor when it's a
Sally May representative we would say is
immoral and gross so there's practices
in those Industries uh the way credit
card companies go after us and the
experimentation they do we would say
that's pretty gross but as far as a
company goes a company's a company and
it doesn't really have a moral compass
yeah as far as that goes do you think
there's any way for a credit card
company to do it right for a credit card
company to take what you say and say you
know what we're going to fix the problem
it's still going to be credit but we're
going to solve these issues every issue
that you say well this lady called into
the Ramsey show this week and it was so
funny she was like yeah well uh I'm with
this nonprofit now that's helping me
with my credit card debt and Capital One
is the one who told me to reach out to
them I was like you're going to trust a
credit card company to help you get out
of the debt that they got you into that
makes no it does because they want to
get paid back if they default on her
they're not they're getting Pennies on
the dollar Mak sense they're like well
we can get her money back we'll be doing
her a service but overall I just don't I
don't trust credit card companies with a
39 and a half foot pole you know I you
know what the terms were of that like
what she signed up for I don't know I
kept asking her she didn't know I was
just like this sounds like a scam it
sounds like one of these debt relief
settlement companies that you sign up
for that you pay them a bunch of money
and they tank your credit on purpose and
then doesn't resolve the issue so
anytime you're using
debt to move around to pay off other
debt it's just you're not actually
solving the root problem and what I
found is people who avoid credit card
debt completely and avoid credit cards
they tend to just have more of their
income at their disposal because they're
not tempted it's really hard to go into
credit card debt when you don't have a
credit card that's the bottom line at
the end of the day you can't spend more
than you make if you can't spend more
than you make but before we get into
that obviously if you're watching this
episode you think Financial Health is
incredibly important and dare I say I
think there's something more important
physical health I tend to agree with
that I know for myself I've been doing
my best to get to the gym every single
day throughout this last year I feel so
much better I work a lot better and the
one thing that's actually made the
biggest Improvement is my diet funny you
say that Grant because that's actually
my New Year's resolution I want to get
shredded like Justin Waller type
shredded I want that eight pack of abs
and today's sponsor hero is here to help
hero makes my favorite foods that I want
to indulge on and eat all the time but
in a very healthy tasty way like for
those una aware herob bread has become a
daily staple of mine every single
morning because of its soft fluffy
texture and rich flavors that make it
constantly taste like it just came
freshly baked out of the oven and what's
even crazier than their flavor gam is
their nutrition facts just just listen
to this guys their hero tortilla Which I
absolutely love I made an amazing
quesadilla out of it zero grams net
carbs zero grams of sugar 80 calories 7
g of protein and 15 gam of fiber on top
of that gram I made a barbecue steak
sandwich with a hero sliced white bread
it had 0 g of net carbs 0 g of sugar 45
calories 5 g of protein and 11 G of
fiber even for myself I've started
started tracking calories lately and
this makes a huge difference because I'm
not wasting calories on bread that I
would buy from the store that tastes
worse than what you would get with herob
bread so you may as well just eat hero
bread instead so guys at the very least
just give it a shot I'm very confident
you're going to absolutely love it just
like Graham and I and they're also
offering at 10% off your entire first
order at hero.com again that's hero.com
slist with the link Down Below in the
description to place your order today
and they're also going to be baking
croissants for every single month in
2024 so you'll enjoy it thank you so
much and now let's get back to the
podcast what do you think is the root
problem cuz you said you can solve it by
just getting rid of your credit cards
but that doesn't necessarily I'm
assuming solve still the root problem in
which why people go into debt couldn't
that be akin to saying well you know get
people off drugs by just eliminating
drugs if drugs didn't exist no one would
be addicted to it then wouldn't it just
go to something else um I mean if you
look at addiction is a it's a strong
form I some people have spending
addiction
but
forver I'm not addicted to cards yeah I
have and I to maximize rewards but I'm
not addicted um and so credit cards are
a different Beast because we've
socialized them to the point where it's
so normal um and I have a quote from
Dave in the book of credit cards have
become the cigarette of the financial
world it's normal but I think it's a bad
habit that is slowly killing people but
it's not one of those where it's like
it's not meth you know what I mean like
you can live a long time and still smoke
cigarettes and some live a long
and they're fine and they live normales
but I still think you'd be better off
with your health and your Financial
Health without it so that's the big
thesis there and I walk through eight
different character archetypes in the
book that I think will hit someone
reading or listening where they go
that's me I consider myself the perfect
spender all right I've heard I I pay off
my card every month I've never spent a
dime in interest how many times have you
said that or heard that right every time
every time and it makes you feel like
you're winning but here's the thing even
even if you never spend a diamond
interest and you pay it off every month
that still leaves you with zero doar it
does not mean you're moving ahead
financially it just means you're not
getting behind and I want people to move
ahead and I think playing this game is
just sort of this Monopoly game created
by the credit card companies to make us
feel like we're winning I'd rather you
have no debt but I think it's better to
use your own money and I think you make
different decisions when you do that so
you did make the claim that I'm guessing
is based in some sort of data that if
you have a credit card versus a debit
card you're PR to spending more money on
a month-to-month basis with the credit
card yes and I cite an MIT study that
was done it used fmri technology and it
scanned the brain when people use credit
cards and what's Wild is that not only
did they say hey when you swipe that
card it sort of releases the breakes on
spending but not only that it it hits
the accelerator and causes you to spend
more which is a pretty wild thing they
already knew that you know spending with
with that little friction spending other
people's money it's going to sort of
like release the brakes a little bit but
not only that it causes you to actually
spend more on top of that which is
compounding the problem now I've seen a
similar study that found when you start
spending money that you spend more money
as a result of spending because you're
already in a habit regardless of credit
or not I forget what the exact study is
but a philosopher I believe in like the
1800s who started looking at buying
furniture oh and he bought furnit he
bought like a new chair in his living
room and then all of a sudden everything
else looked outdated because he got the
chair so then he wanted the couch so he
got a new couch and then the rug looks
weird because those two are new and the
rug's kind of get a rug wardrobes are
very similar when you buy a shirt well
now I need a new pair of pants to go
with the new shirt and a new pair of
shoes and that's just a spending uh
Habit that I think is it's just a
cascading effect is regardless of debit
or credit if you spend I would like to
see a study if people start spending do
they spend more because they've already
spent something it's floodgates already
opened yeah well that's how I feel about
it I mean with with credit scores and
credit cards it's sort of this Gateway
into other types of debt and once you
have a payment on one side of your life
what's a payment on another side what's
a car payment what's a mortgage payment
and I think we need to retrain our brain
to stop thinking in terms of payments
and start thinking in terms of Freedom
with our income because that's really
you know we say it's your greatest
wealth building tool and when you give
that to lenders even if you're paying
off a card every month you're still
giving it away and that's money I think
you would have you would have kept more
of your money if you had spent your own
and I say my sort of end thesis in the
chapter is when it hurts less it costs
more when it hurts less emotionally
which is what happens when you swipe
instead of handing over $100 bills in
cash we would Revolt if we had to hand
over $100 bills to pay taxes every year
but because it sort of comes out of our
paycheck or when we spend it sort of
just gets swiped on a card we don't feel
the emotion of that money leaving our
bank account just a digital number
changes slightly it's similar with
casinos and chips I heard one of the
reasons they switched to chips I mean
not only is it easier to carry around
but because you don't associate that
with money it's a lot easier to spend
chips than it is to be like here's 100
100 100 well think about that with with
credit card points why do you think they
move from cash back numbers to you get
150,000 points it sounds like an amazing
huge number instead of going here's $500
they go here's 150,000 points credit
card companies watching this could
actually do some crazy stuff with that
with marketing and saying you're going
to get a million points but in the fine
print is say the million points that's a
$100 yeah when IAL I I actually talked
to an X Capital One employee and she was
talking about all the experiments they
run and the ab tests when they said hey
when we switch to points it causes
people mentally to flip on a different
part of their brain because they don't
associate points versus money it just
feels like I'm winning it feels like I'm
at Chuck-E-Cheese and so the stuff that
she unpacked it just made it even like
more gross to how these credit card
companies come after us to where I'm
like even if you think you're winning
you're not and someone else is losing at
the expense of you winning what are some
of the other secrets that that person
told you about credit card companies oh
my gosh well the fact that they run
Capital One in particular runs 10,000
experiments on consumers every year that
boggled my mind like there's only 365
days in a year how is this possible
they're constantly running these AB
tests to figure out what's going to get
people to spend more money um that part
was was pretty gross and then just all
the amount of like they can devalue your
points at any time what are some of the
tests they run you ask didn't get into
the specifics of what they did but it's
a lot of switching the mentality and the
verbage around it and so but I think a
lot of it is when they move from cash
back to points that there's a reason all
the credit card companies have moved to
talking about points in airline miles
and so I break down how the airline
miles work and how much you'd actually
have to spend and it's like 50 Grand in
spending gets you $250 in Rewards or
$500 and so it's just when people tell
me I get a free flight and I spend how I
normally would I'm like you would not
normally spend spend $50,000 in a year
the one counter to that is that mostly
you'd be able to get those free flights
with a sign up bonus which have a much
lower spent so let's just say your
example $750 which is about uh the sign
up bonus for a higher end credit card or
like mid- tier to Upper mid usually that
would require a spending of anywhere
between $4 to $10,000 in three months so
all of a sudden then the cash back seems
a lot higher when it's just the signup
bonus versus keeping the card for years
and like year three spending 50 Grand a
lot of people most people do is they go
like well I wasn't planning on spending
10 grand like 10 grand in three months
is a lot cuz you can't you know most
people can't put their mortgage and
utilities on there and so we're talking
about consumer spending groceries gas so
what do they do well we'll eat out again
this month because we got to hit them we
got to hit the number and so I think
mentally and psychologically they know
you're going to spend more by doing this
in order to get the bonus and maybe
you'll use the bonus maybe you won't we
found a lot of people foro the bonuses
forget it expires whatever the thing is
uh they're not actually utilizing it to
its full capacity to that end it's
causing people to go into debt in order
to get a bonus which then negates any
reward that now see that I would agree
with that a lot of the bonuses go unused
and the same thing with gift cards there
was this whole study that I read
recently on gift cards of how many of
them just go un sitting on there and
it's and it's genius from the business
perspective because essentially to them
it's a free loan businesses are able to
get 0% interest because you're buying a
gift card and it's a honestly it's a
50-50 whether or not you're ever going
to use it so it's free money for the
businesses we tell ourselves well it's
free money I might as well do it for the
free money and I just I just think that
mentality causes more people to go broke
than it does causes them to ever build
any wealth you know and I get it like no
one's claiming they're Building Wealth
with credit card uh points but at the
same time they see it as like a piece of
being smart financially and I just I
just disagree fundamentally that I think
Graham would be just as well off if he
stuck to a debit card if not better off
so I will say my perspective changed a
little bit after chapter 3 hey that's a
win the only reason why it changed a
little bit is because I actually saw how
bad the data was on it which was like
the main thing for me was 49% or
whatever number it is can't pay off
their monthly credit card statement now
for me that's a really really really sad
because they're getting charged
exorbitant interest rates it's just
going to keep them under right and it
brings me back to this conversation that
we had with Grant Cardone actually and I
was saying it's better to encourage
people to get high-paying salaried
positions and he was saying no spend
your last few thousand doar on education
to start your own business but most
businesses fail in the first 5 years 50%
of businesses fail so you're like
setting them up to fail a said they had
bought my course may they would sure you
could make that argument but his whole
thing is like if you're just persistent
and you keep trying you keep trying I'm
like sure if you play it super smart but
if you look at all available data people
do not win when they're trying that
everyone should start a business now
here's the thing if you're super smart
about it yes I believe the the percent
would change I'm sure 90 some percent
could succeed in business if they
continue pushing year after year after
year after year get persistent and
continue working on it the same with
credit cards if you're super smart and
super disciplined with your spending and
you don't spend more because of it and
you never allow them to charge you
interest because of it then I think that
you can get ahead but if you look at all
available data I would never encourage
every single person listening right now
to start your own business because I
know most I know most fail I would not
encourage everyone listening to this to
start day trading because I know most
day Traders lose money so now if I'm
looking at data around credit cards it's
like well most people lose right if
you're smart you'll win and I do think
it's good to win right I do think it's
good to get the cash back on credit
cards I think it's good to get the sign
up bonuses I think it's really nice to
go into the lounges when I'm flying but
I think it's important about being
intentional about the decisions that
you're making rather than being you know
super I would say motivated to get a
credit card because oh we're pleased to
accept you into the card or by a sign up
bonus and you're not actually spending
the points and stuff like that I think
it's important to be intentional about
it but before we go into that you might
have noticed that we're now filming in
4k we're really proud of that we've come
a long way because if you go to our
Channel and you sort by oldest you'll be
able to see our first video and it was
pretty bad but it got us started and we
were able to grow to almost 900,000
subscribers without anything fancy and
our sponsor streamyard is there to help
you out creating good content does not
need a cost an arm and a leg and with
today's sponsor streamyard you can
create high quality content right from
your browser with just the click of a
button all you need is a camera and an
internet connection and you'll be able
to stream throughout multiple platforms
at the exact same time from YouTube to
Instagram to Facebook to LinkedIn and
more getting on every single platform is
something we've been personally working
on in the ice coffee hour for example
you may have seen us on Tik Tok or
Instagram which has been doing
incredibly well for us and streamyard is
there to make it extremely simple and
also free with a free package with the
link Down Below in the description again
it's completely free and all you need to
do is click the link Down Below in the
description to start creating high
quality content today and streamyard has
been a fantastic tool for us we've used
them for years now highly recommend them
the link is down below in the
description to get started today for
free now with that said let's get back
to the episode I just know human nature
is you know I talked to a girl today man
on the street in Las Vegas and I was
asking her about her credit card like
hey how many do you have what do you use
and she's like I have this one then I
have the apple one I was like what made
you get the apple one she's like well
it's titanium and I saw my dad with it
I'm like that's human
like whether we want to admit it or not
that's humanity and I talk about the
book the actual history of credit cards
and it's funny it started with Frank
mcnamer in a diner in New York and he
forgot his wallet he was so embarrassed
that he asked hey we need a credit
system so where if I forget my wallet I
can still pay the first credit card was
born the diner club and the first one
was actually made of cardboard not quite
the flex of the titanium cards but the
fact that we're lured in by she
literally said well the card's just
pretty like that's an insane reason to
get a credit card and but it's one of
the reasons and one of the main reasons
people do it there's a reason we love
the YX it's shiny and thick and the
thicker it is the more well off you are
it's a game they've created I just like
the idea of being morally consistent and
if I wouldn't encourage everybody to be
a day trader I don't know if I would say
here to everybody that you should get a
credit card when you look at the data
here's thing here's the thing though
with your example like business or day
trading I I think it's a terrible thing
to do that out of desperation for money
if someone says hey I'm broke I need to
make $1,000 you would never say start a
business CU like you said so many people
would fail or a sign up bonus but I
think it's like hey I got this idea and
I want to be an entrepreneur and if it
fails or succeeds I just want to try it
then I think it's Fant I think the the
experience that you get from running a
business or even day trading could be
really invaluable even if you lose the
experience that you get from that I
think is is invaluable I agree and I do
think there's some selection bias if you
look at the people watching your videos
of like the five best credit cards to
get in 2023 I think if you look at the
results of that more people are probably
winning than losing huge dude imagine in
these videos of like you should get this
card because it's Titanium because
you're actually outlining like how you
can be smart with it and it's not just
like oh get this card because well and
no one's reading the fine print if you
ask people what the interest rate is on
their credit card they'd have no idea
most of them unless they're they have a
balance and they're having to pay that
you know what I mean like they all get
star out of the bonuses and not looking
at here's what could happen you you may
get 2% you may as well get 22% in
interest another hard thing though is is
there any significance to paying that
interest for a few months to get a slap
on the wrist and learn your lesson that
you need to be more intentional about
your spending or you silly to be like I
think we should touch the hot stove to
figure out that stoves shouldn't be T
need tou that I think some people need
to I think people need a reality people
sometimes need a rock bottom to have
that I've had it moment and we that's
what we see on the Ramy show yeah I mean
we everyone at some point that has
followed the Ramsey plan has some level
of of that didn't feel good I don't want
to live like that anymore you have to
get to that point so I think Americans
are just too comfortable sitting on our
own poopy diapers at this point but the
people who are ready to make a change
they've had life happen and they have
that emergency and they didn't have the
emergency fund to cover it and it was
scary Co did that for a lot of people I
mean it spooked to everyone like crap we
got to get aaack together we've been
just like spending spending spending no
nothing in savings nothing in retirement
like we don't know what life's going to
throw at us so we better be prepared
what was the most surprising thing from
going to people on the street and
talking to them oh man I mean Vegas has
you know there's a lot of interesting
people on on the Vegas trip that you
talk to but the most shocking thing was
just I was asking people like did you
budget for this trip how much do you
plan on spending how are you paying for
this and the amount of people who just
did not have answers it was just like
I'm just going to swipe and I'll worry
about it later like that lack of there's
no planning there's no delayed
gratification it's all instant
gratification YOLO
that's a problem for future me and the
problem is future you is going to wake
up going crap like you got a financial
hangover from how you spent in December
and so that's the problem I'm saying is
no one's making a budget going all right
we're going to plan $1,000 we're going
to pay cash for it instead they're like
well I'll get the cash back and I'll
make the payments what percentage of
people said that though that they just
swiped the card and didn't think about
it I would say six out of 10 people have
that mentality and we know six out of 10
people live paycheck to paycheck so I
think there's a strong correlation there
yeah I think the problem with a lot of
these things such as like being
financially disciplined losing weight
and stuff like that is that there's
never a stark punishment until it
finally rains then it pours like you're
not going to be suffering from swiping
your credit card for maybe a couple of
years and then all of the sudden
everything adds up like you you know
gave an example of in your own personal
life in your book where it just got so
much and then it infected every other
area of your life yeah no one opens a
credit card thinking I'm probably going
to carry a balance everyone thinks
thinks I'm going to be the guy that pays
it off early on time and I'll never
carry a balance part of it is that the
minimum payment isn't even that painful
so if you just can pay $100 a month but
carry a $5,000 balance it's not that bad
it's not even a slap on the wrist it's
just slightly pay off or you just never
pay it off but I mean what are the re
it's it's numbers on a screen to a lot
of people so see the 5,000 it doesn't
matter 22% APR is which is the average
credit card interest now it's at an
all-time high credit card debts at
alltime high of a trillion dollars and
we're all wondering why we're broke
fighting you know we're trying to fight
inflation people broke that's what I
want to know it's they're not well
they're consumer spending is way up so
if they are broke they don't seem to
care very much I see such conflicting
studies some have more money than they
ever had there's 6 trillion dollars
right now sitting in Money Market funds
and in cash and treasuries more than
ever but it also seems like anecdotally
you hear stories of people who are doing
worse than ever but statistically it
seems like people are better off today
overall than they were in 2019 well I
mean America is an amazing country so
even a bad day for us is a great day for
any other country so we're just so
spoiled and there's a lot of entitlement
here and people have great incomes you
know people like to complain but most
people have great incomes it's not an
income problem it's an expense problem
you know we see this people making six
figures are still living paycheck to
paycheck the data shows so that tells me
it's not that you just make more money
and your problems are solved you just
have life style creep happen and uh you
know you make 100,000 you're going to
spend 120 and that compounds over time
um causing a lot of people to feel broke
regardless of their income so what do
you think of the long-term consequences
of this if people aren't saving up for
retirement maybe it's like this younger
generation that wants that instant
gratification well they don't want to
wait 30 years to tap into a 401k piggy
bank what do you think is going to
happen in the future then to these
people because this seems like it's a
huge population of people that are doing
this yeah well I think the younger
Generations in a lot of ways are way
smarter than than our parents generation
like the fact that they have access to
all this information is amazing the
problem is there's so many more traps
out there and I've always said if you
follow the trends you're going to follow
the traps our parents didn't have
options it was you put money into your
retirement account and that's it
nowadays it's like do I do single stocks
do I get into crypto do I do real estate
the options are so overwhelming that
there's this you know paralysis by
analysis and people either don't do
anything or they do a bunch of things
but don't really make progress in any of
it and so that's what I'm worried about
with the next Generations is that
they're not focused and there's no
consistency over time and you guys know
like Building Wealth is consistently
you're dollar cost averaging into the
S&P 500 over time it's the boring move
but it's the one that consistently will
cause you to build wealth see I just
think it's so much easier for people who
pay attention to get ahead just because
so many people are not and just give in
to whatever they desire in the moment
like I think it's easier than ever if if
you put your head down and you want to
stay disciplined you're going to get
ahead very easily and that's the I mean
the thesis of the book is like the
people say the little man can't get
ahead it's harder than ever in America
today inflation and the housing market
and the guy in the White House and what
I found is you can get ahead in America
today if you just follow a really simple
boring unsexy controversial Upstream
path of getting out of debt staying out
of debt have an emergency fund invest
15% into proven things like the stock
market over a long period of time pay
off your G house and don't hang on to it
in retirement with a second mortgage and
a helck on it and you're going to be
okay and that's regardless of income
whether you make 40,000 or 400,000 if
you follow those principles you will be
okay but most people want to make it
more complicated they think they're
smarter than that there's there's Pride
there's fear there's greed and it causes
us to make really unwise decisions and
then people call into the show at 60
going I'm screwed what do I do and it's
just harder at 60 to undo some of those
decisions so that in the simp terms
would be your advice to make any viewer
watching right now A Millionaire yeah
and I don't here's the thing I know a
lot of people out there are saying well
leveraging debt is a part of Building
Wealth and while some people have done
that the majority of people will go
broke faster and so to me getting out of
debt and using your powerful wealth
building tool your income is your best
path to wealth so what's the difference
between people who leverage debt
successfully and make money versus those
who do not and lose money well it's
there's there's types you know like
leveraging a real estate debt for
example versus trying to leverage
something else like margin or options
calls in the stock market like that
stuff is insane Jack don't do it and
Jack all about losing lots of money I
got so there's you know there's
different types of of debt leverage out
there uh but a lot of the difference is
luck and timing if you're going to be
honest of like people who have done it
well or successfully or even looking at
crypto you know it's like people didn't
know what crypto was going to do or is
going to
so the that have become millionaires
itn't because they were so brilliant I
think it's a really small population of
people though I think it's education
that's the main differentiating factor
between those who leverage debt properly
and those who do it poorly yeah I mean
there's a lot of Education there's
strategy involved I've just found for
the average person there's a 100%
success rate if you get out of debt and
do it my way versus a 7% success rate
leveraging debt this way and so to me
I'm all about what is your shest best
path it may be slower but you'll get
there I would agree with that and then
the thing that I mostly have a problem
with with the anti-d philosophy give me
the beef the home loan why is it such a
big deal to to have a 30-year fixed rate
mortgage at two and a half% that's what
I have right now now you would probably
argue if I had the cash to pay it off we
know you won't you have the cash you can
do it today I'm making money on
inflation like I this money I'm able to
invest in other things put in a 30y
treasury I could put in a treasury and
get more money you could how much I'm
losing on interest My Philosophy Jack is
in the and the write off the that's my
favorite the write off sending $2,500 to
the IRS is somehow better than sending
$10,000 to A lender that's the write off
right
there it takes the 2.8 down to a 2.3
effective that's what the write-off does
that hurts my brain 2.3 inflation is way
higher treasuries you lock in a 30-y
year right now looking at a very
specific window of time yes and so
things are looking great for Jack on
paper right now but to me we just don't
know what the future holds and I would
rather reduce the risk have more peace
have that money back in my life
obviously you don't have a huge mortgage
payment you know to begin with you got a
bunch of Roommates so you're doing okay
but for the average American out there
hanging on to the mortgage is not
benefiting them in any significant way I
think it would I think it would reduce
the risk not to pay off the mortgage
because all of a sudden yeah you're
going to do some ma cuz you're saying
you're saying the money's locked up
money locked up let's say the house is
400 Grand you have a $300,000 mortgage I
think having $300,000 about situation my
house is paid off the money's stuck in
the house I can't access it I'm not
going to do a cash out refi not going to
do any of that why am I screwed and what
risk do I have in your position I don't
think you would be screwed I think in a
lot of people's positions where they
don't have a paid off house and the
choice is do I sell my stocks and you
know everything I have over here my
investments to pay in the house let's
say they pay off the house all of a
sudden they lose their job and let's
just say they have children and health
care expenses and things like this and
they need money and all of a sudden
they're negative every month in that
situation yeah of course they can get
another job or something like that but I
would value the liquidity of having
money on the sidelines much more than
having it tied up in a property well we
call that an emergency fund and that's
part of it we tell people have a 3 to
six- month emergency fund before you
become a homeowner and so let's say
things went downhill I would have my
emergency fund there ready to protect me
and the idea of me being out of work for
6 months I mean like I'd swallow my
pride and go do whatever gig I needed to
do until I got back on my feet and for
most people there's very little
Interruption of income some people don't
have to touch the emergency fund at all
but if they do it's there to cover them
during that period of time so to me I'm
like I don't need the wiggle room
because I have my emergency fund part of
it too is 30 years from now let's even
say 20 years from now the money that
you're paying off is going to be so de
valued with inflation I mean we could
see the way the dollar is going it's
going down I if we see a small amount of
deflation at some point so be it but I
think longterm they're going to keep
printing money you also you believe in
the housing market and it's going to
continue to appreciate correct so my
house my house is appreciated way more
than my investment accounts yes but but
had you leveraged your money and let's
say bought two properties you would have
doubled that appreciation potentially
yeah but there's risk and headache
involved and you know it could have gone
over 30 years I'd bet on the housing
market over 10 I have no clue but over
30 50 years I think it's a solid
investment personally yeah I mean real
estate is great and I think if you did
it with cash there's there's less risk
on paper less upside and in real life
you know but there's and you get more
cash flow with a cash flow property you
know you talked to Dave Ramsey about
this and he he you know audited your
portfolio he's like the only I do
different is pay it all off you got the
money but you like your cash position
California is a good example of those
mortgages they're at three a half% 3.3
give or take but I'm paying
50% taxes to California when
everything's said and done with state
income tax and everything like that so I
I that three and a half% is really just
take that down by half it's so cheap you
know what else I've seen with these low
interest rates that's actually becoming
a curse is people have handcuffs now oh
yeah they don't want to let go they
won't sell it cuz like well I can't get
another loan for 3 and half% so they're
stuck the other thing no one's talking
about is a a tax basis on these
properties that have gone up in value
that have doubled in value in like 5
years now all of a sudden it's not just
your mortgage rate that goes up it's
your tax basis if you were to sell and
buy anything else all of a sudden your
property taxes are also going to be
going up significantly so that's one of
the reasons that like if I could snap my
fingers and keep my tax bases in
California transfer that somewhere else
I would love to do I just dump
everything I have just to get out of the
state but don't you think if you had
everything paid off you'd be less
worried about letting go of an a low
interest mortgage um if you're going to
just pay cash for the next property
you'd have more options truthfully
versus feeling stuck like I can't like
go of that I mean those are the calls
because it's so attractive that that's
the only reason why is it's so
attractive to me to have a 3% interest
rate for 30 years especially in a high
income tax state like that to me is so
good that it's like why do I want to
give up such a good thing so it's not
like I feel handcuffed I only feel
handcuffed because it's like this is so
good that I can't give it up exact me
that is a form of handcuffs you know
what I mean golden handcuffs we'll call
them that sure golden handcuffs it
limits Mobility but it's so good that
you know the good outweighs kind of
being stuck and holding these properties
sure with a low tax basis very first
world problems the way that I see it is
in my personal experience in Graham's
personal experience in another viewer
let's say if they're very intentional
about the way that they're spending and
taking on debt and stuff like that then
I think it's a win I think that you're
just winning at the end of the day if
you look at your financial statements
taking on debt and being smart with it
maybe using credit cards and stuff like
that and you're extremely intentional
and smart about it year after year you
will win more than the other person that
isn't barring spending more because it's
a credit card rather than cash out of
your account barring that yeah um so I
think that's great but I also think the
only other thing that could sway me is
this peace that everyone says that you
get when you pay off debt and I want to
know like I just talked about this with
Andre Andre J was talking about like he
was like could you create a mathematical
formula for the Peace of Mind emotional
and I was like I wish that's the only
thing I've been curious about that's
what needs
needs it an equation where he could be
like all right the peace of mind is X Z
multipli by you know fun there's no way
to do it I remember this conversation I
had with you a few years back Graham so
Graham and I when we were in uh Los
Angeles together we would go on this
walk almost every single day I missed
those walk romtic I know it so cute dude
we came up with the best ideas one hour
during the weekdays we take like a two
mile wow amazing so good well we lived
together so that's when we did it and
here's an interesting thing when you're
actually walking your brain works more
efficiently I believe that so there's
like some studies I can prove that I
don't know what they're called but yeah
walking backwards inefficient not good
exactly no but we we would do this walk
every single day and one day Graham out
of nowhere never heard him say anything
like this ever before he was like you
know I'm really tempted to pay off every
property I have I said that you said
that I don't remember I honestly don't
remember you DayQuil or something like
struck me that you said that and I was
like what are you talking about you're
like just the peace of mind and you're
you were like thinking about it because
I don't think that I think obviously you
had a lot less money back then so you
were thinking to yourself like you know
like now you you're more affluent so you
think okay it's okay if I take on more
debt still a smaller percentage of the
amount of money I have but back in the
day I think it was a more significant
portion and so you were considering just
paying off everything and living more
affluently which I I found really
interesting and and I was wondering like
if you could measure out that piece back
then would it have convinced you in
hindsight I'm glad I didn't I think I
remember what was going through my mind
at the time was that um Co was kind of
Uncertain the markets were a bit
uncertain and I had this cash and I was
thinking what would be the benefit cuz I
just moved into a new home and this was
like my expenses tripled by going from a
duplex into like an actual house and so
I was kind of I I was stressed out from
going from like living on $1800 a month
to like I think at the time it was like
10 like it was a huge bump up and so
that stressed me out for a while in
hindsight I'm glad I didn't do that mhm
but I want to know like cuz even he was
tempted and this is is like you know Mr
proad over here the anti- Ramsey but if
we can somehow figure out this peace
that people experience when they pay off
their debt in another form other than
like screaming right like the anti-
scream because I think that's hard to
measure if we if if I'm sure someone
much smarter than me can find some
equation that may convince Graham okay
so in your own personal life when you
paid it off well I think also like
having a family and getting married and
having a baby it it just changes the
level of risk you know if I was a young
man making what Graham makes I would
probably have a similar risk tolerance
but at this stage of life as I get older
as I you know find what my priorities
are in life and what my goals are things
have just shifted like the goal post has
just moved and to me less risk is going
to create a more peaceful family
environment like I'm not going to fight
with my wife when we don't have payments
you know what I mean like we just had a
baby four months ago and if she wants to
stay home it's not like a oh gosh we got
to pay the bills and if we lose your
income it's just like cool you do what
you want babe like whatever your your
heart leads you to do and it just
changes the way you have um it changes
the way you make decisions it gives you
more options more margin more peace more
joy and that's the whole thesis of this
book is if we break free from the system
we get out of debt we build wealth the
right way we can have what we're really
after which I think is those things it's
not just more money we want what the
things money can't buy which I think is
the emotional piece I'm just so curious
what that would be for me and the
unfortunate part is it would cost a lot
of money at this point with all the
mortgages to pay them all off what would
it take uh give me a number what to pay
off the mortgages million bucks two
million bucks 3.9 and that's all the
mortgages in California everything it
would cause you to be completely debt
free have you done the math on what your
new cash flow yeah it doesn't make sense
because you know even if that money is
in treasuries making five and a half
percent to pay off five and i' like my
cash flow would go down like in history
that we've seen these kinds of numbers
or I could lock it in I mean I could
lock in for the next 30 30 years
hypothetically if I wanted to and still
get four something which is still higher
than the mortgages so I feel like it
would be a downgrade financially in
terms of cash flow and then I'm paying a
high cash flow to invest wouldn't you uh
yes but i' would be paying higher taxes
from the California portion because it
would have less write off California
problem I think it's time that's a
certain that's a California problem it
would be a lot of money to have that
feeling and I'm not sure if I would feel
any better because of it well I think
truthfully in both of your situations
the key to your success and your wealth
is the income it's your savings rate
it's your ability to have a giant chunk
of money that you can deploy into
investments in real estate and so it's
not necessarily that debt was the ticket
it's you guys found ways to increase
your income to such a point where you
can worry about like here's an example
right now I could take let's just say4
million bucks I could take $4 million
put it in commercial real estate here in
Las Vegas and get anywhere between 7 to
8% I would be able to depreciate that
property against the income and for the
most part almost all of it would be
tax-free so I can make eight let's let's
even say conservatively six and a half
percent that would be more than enough
to cover all the debt servicing every
year I make that I'll pay the debt two
years so like from a financial
standpoint I'm looking I don't see any
good deals oh yeah yeah I've I've been
looking I I'm in the camp that I think
commercial real estate's got to take a
hit and I could be totally wrong but
I've noticed prices go down so far so in
the last year they've gone down about 10
to 15% in Vegas and I just don't think
theyit I feel like as cash buyer at this
juncture though you could find some
deals um everything I like has multiple
offers Believe It or Not dang and
they're going over asking Hot Market
yeah come to Nashville I mean it's it's
also very hot well the issue and I know
we're getting nuanced here but a lot of
buyers coming from California and
they're parking their money in Vegas and
anything in Vegas that they get even if
it's at a 5 and a half% return a five
cap they're doing it because hey it's
better than having our money in
California and we have to 1031 it so
let's just take what we could get so
anything anything that's decent
California buyers or New York buyers
they're just taking their money they're
putting it here or move to Tennessee no
state income tax solve some problems
yeah but capital gains taxes there
that's not going to kill you you're not
selling property sell if I sell you know
you never know if but you wouldn't
because you have that sweet low interest
loan not any yeah here but you know
anything else you buy you're not going
to get that not unless you pay cash boom
what I find interesting is you said we
acquire money to all of the things that
money can't buy which I I've never heard
it phrased that way and I do think that
kind of makes sense when you say that
your wife you know she had the kid you
guys had the kid and she didn't have to
go back did I did you contributed in
your own way in the George way you
contributed sure right so change diapers
right exactly so you know she doesn't
have to go back to work she's able to
stay at home stay with the kid and
everything because you have this like
debt freak lifestyle which I've never
heard it said in that way and that is a
very compelling way it's like I mean
what are we working so hard to get all
of this money
for life is short life ends you know and
once you have enough granted you know
whatever that enough amount is then sure
maybe you can accelerate the amount of
time that it takes to get to the point
where you're getting the stuff money
can't buy I mean yeah when you when you
look at really successful wealthy people
they'll tell you like time freedom is
everything and now money can buy
conveniences like the personal chef or
the personal trainer or whatever the
those things are um that allow you to
have the life you want and I just I've
rarely seen debt allow people to to have
that life any more freely um and the
people that I look up to and my mentors
they have more time and money than ever
and it's largely because they live a
debt-free lifestyle and these aren't
like billionaire business owners these
are people who are from all over the
country visiting us and they're saying
hey I was able to cash flow all five
kids college thanks to following your
principles living debt free paid for
house we're baby steps millionaires now
and you know this was on a teacher
salary that inspires me cuz it it's not
about the Grant Cardone if you don't
make 400 Grand you suck you know what I
mean like some people just want to be
teachers like we need teachers in
America and they may never make six
figures and I still want them to build
wealth and so a part of it is just it's
comforting to me that anyone can build
wealth regardless of their income
obviously more income helps but if you
just follow these principles you will
get there and you will have the things
on the other side like we talked about
and so that's why I talk about money so
we can stop talking about money cuz too
many of us are talking about it in a
negative way we're stressed out what's
going to happen what could be what could
I have done with this money and I want
people to have Joo instead of fomo the
joy of missing out of saying I don't
need I can just run my race take care of
my family take care of my business go on
the vacation I want to take and not have
to worry about any of this stuff so how
has paying off your debt had any other
tangential benefits in your life you
explained the thing about your wife
being able to stay home with the kids oh
yeah any other things like some sort of
inner peace that didn't exist beforehand
or other ways I mean it's it's hard to
say because I'm not the the amount of
time that I'm saving I know it sounds
weird by not playing the game of the
system by not worrying about the credit
score and the auto loan like we just
paid cash to get my wife an SUV and I
didn't have to haggle over financing I
just want here's the price there you go
and the finance office is calling me
being like I don't understand why you're
paying cash you should be leasing that's
what I do with all my vehicles I at
least on my vehicles I'm like lady you
don't understand you got
the I I didn't have the emotional energy
to even fight this lady in the finance
office I was like lady I'm writing a
check I'm going to be done with it and
to me like the time saving and the
mental energy and brain calories I'm not
burning over playing the game of a toxic
money culture is so worth it and so it
just feels nice I'm never worrying about
there's no bills coming to our house
like the utility bills get paid and
that's it what's your overhead every
month utilities and insurance and
property taxes I'm guessing that comes
out to 1,000 bucks and then what about
food Healthcare oh I guess Healthcare
Ramsey would Healthcare comes out of my
paycheck and now it's more thanks to a
baby uh and so that's you know a few
hundred bucks a month Max for a premium
you know 250 bucks maybe okay um what
about food food I mean we are now that
we don't have any payments we do eat out
more or we'll get more you know frozen
meals and and less cooking at home less
toiling over the rice and beans and so
we have a food budget of probably on
average 700 bucks 800 bucks and you know
we'll go out to eat have some nice date
nights and some good meals at home but
we don't really like we don't have to
like you know worry about grocery
shopping it's like we'll get what we
need and we it sounds to me with like
car insurance and gas and other
maintenance 3,000 maybe 3500 a month
yeah our hard expenses you're looking at
three three grand a month to like cover
everything we need and so anything above
that is money that I can invest into my
girls college fund a brokerage account
giving generously saving up for the
vacation saving up to upgrade my car you
know my my my gram you'll be so upset my
Tesla window fell into my door and will
not come back up there's no way that
happened I rolled the window down on car
it's the motor it's the motor it's like
the power window regulators out yeah
it's about 600 bucks now it maybe more
because it's Tesla sure and they up
charge but 300 the cheapest 800 the most
expensive I dealt with that just real
quickly explain how you got this Tesla
because it's so funny what like how I
just paid for it I've not heard the
story Jack I'm curious didn't you buy
like the most amount of mileage Tesla
that oh yes so I was looking this is
funny soed the we paid off the house and
so I dangled the carrot of I'm not going
to upgrade my 09 Honda Civic with the
bumper hanging off until I pay off the
house that was my goal and so we paid
off the house and I went all right I'm
going to going to buy a Honda my dream
car was a hybrid Honda Accord my wife
laughed at me but I was like I'm a man
of utility that's a sweet ride you get
like an
EXL Primo I could not find one she was
nervous cuz the ladies love that car the
ladies driving yeah so I could see why
she did not want you ladies love an
accord so I was looking for like a 2018
this is in like 2021 I'm looking for
like a 2018 Accord Hybrid under 30 grand
I could not find one across the country
then I stumbled upon a 2013 Model S
Tesla four owners two minor accidents
165,000 mil and I was like I'm getting a
Tesla and so I ended up checking it out
I was the first one to you know inquire
there was 25 people that were waiting
you're kidding the guy was like I need
to know if you're serious because this
car is going to move I was like I've
never even driven an electric car I
don't know so I nervously took it for a
test drive and he was I knew the guy so
I trusted him and I was like I'll take
it and that car was
239 and I took the gamble on a on a high
mileage Tesla so now I'm sitting at
188,000 Miles how has it been since then
it's been great it still has um I mean
the door handle got stuck out I got that
fixed and this window situation I
upgraded the screen to the newer you
know model yeah system but other than
that it's been a great vehicle I mean it
truly I mean this is not an ad for Tesla
but I I respect the heck out of them for
going half a million miles on these
batteries and it's only degraded about
20% so I still get 65 miles range mine
mine had no issues except right when I
got it the AC broke and it was fixed
under warranty within a week and at the
time now this is 2019 this is your model
3 this is model 3 they gave me a p90d
model X for a week as a loner car I
don't know if that still exists I don't
think they do that I think you don't
give you the there's some privilege
there they need back the day they'd give
you the fancy ones yeah so maybe this is
back in the day this I got in with the
model 3 before they were cool yeah just
as they were starting come any issues
with your with yours Jack no no issues
so far no the only thing is the build
quality is not fantastic like obviously
everyone knows this compared to like a a
traditional yeah you could buy a Prius
or something and it's look by the way
the new Prius is oh my God I love them
gorgeous love yeah they just were
they're like oh you think Priuses are
ugly ha then they make the 2024 Prius
and it looks gorgeous I would mind
getting a Prius just because of the
range the one thing I don't like about
the model 3 is if you're driving a long
distance get the long range get that
model S 400 miles yeah that's something
yeah I think it's 405 miles worth it but
it's expensive that's 60 Grand I could
buy two Priuses for that price or you
can sell
S no okay get 10 PR I was so close get
10 Prius like oh that's a great idea
them on turo you'll make a $4 million a
year Well if I put that money down and I
finance the Priuses and I get a hundred
Priuses imagine that on Toro and then I
could start an air we took thisam the
other day and this couple they financed
three cars to use on turo they're
underwater on all three by 15 or 20
grand it was heartbreaking screed I mean
there're they're screwed there's no way
out of this you have to come up with the
money for the difference um to then pay
them off and they're clearly not making
enough from turo to then cover this
cover these payments now that they're
underwater on so they only you got to
just keep them and pay them off cover
the difference or get a loan for the
difference from a credit union which is
going to be hard to do at this point
point so it's real I mean there's sad
situations where people think they get
real star eyed and car loans I have the
whole chapter on car loans in the book
and how they are America's wealth killer
today I truly believe that is as
expensive as they are how high the
interest rates are and how willing we
are to just go into debt for a car the
car loans are something that is largely
unregulated and I did a whole Deep dive
in an old video of mine about the autol
loan industry and they're not regulated
and it's one of the few things that like
when you get a student loan there are
certain bodies of the government that
can reg screw people over yeah pretty
much and make sure they're fair and make
sure that you qualify for it like it's
so stringent to get a mortgage very
stringent to get student loans but car
loans were exactly and leases are even
worse yeah because they don't have to
disclose the interest rate that's baked
into your payment oh absolutely the
other thing is that with auto loans I
think it was something like 30% of
people lie on their application but get
approved anyway so they'll overstate
their income or underestimate their
expenses to be able to get the
and the lenders purposely will Overlook
it they're not going to check anything
they
justers they're not exactly people of
Integrity but they get paid the
dealership and the person originating
the loan get paid as long as you make
your first like two payments yeah
they'll tell you like hey don't pay this
off early because you'll screw me over
on the bonus exactly so as long as they
just make the two payments they could
bundle them together sell them to Hungry
Investors who want a high yield and they
don't care well I I compare dealerships
to uh Gus Fring and Breaking Bad Los
poos Hermanos a front for his drug
operation like that's what dealerships
are yeah the vehicles are just the
vehicle they're actually making money
with lending absolutely and so it's a
really wild that's why they they'll be
like oh you're going to pay cash no no
no no no we're going to charge you more
a thousand that $1,000 incentive was
only if you're financing and it's
because they're making that and more
auto loans I 100% agree with you so
financing any sort of depreciating asset
like that at the interest rates that
you're getting on Carlos and they're
just extending them out well and now
we're seeing on the Ramsey show everyone
is under water on their cars they're
calling in like I'm 20 grand underwater
and I'm like how did we get here they
rolling over negative equity they're
doing all kind of things people thought
that car loans would just or people just
thought the car values would keep going
up they saw 2020 2021 2022 it's like oh
my gosh my used car is worth $10,000
more wow I could make money on cars now
and I can I'm going to buy a Chevy Vault
and it's going to be worth more and
they're going to buy it at the peak of
the market and pay over MSRP for that
just to find out wait in a second it's
not reality I think same thing with
watches too everyone is like oh W these
all these watches certain pects APS the
hype watches are down like 30% from the
peak some are down 50% when did you buy
the town home 2019 how much how much has
that gone up in value like percentage
wise oh it went up we bought it at 300
we sold at 529 three years later the
GT's not gone up that much but it's up
about 30% but it's up about 30% I'm glad
that my personal home beat a luxury toy
that you purchased that's comfor it's up
30% it's pretty good for now no I think
it'll stay well once they find out it's
Grahams can I say I was talking to Andre
and he gave me the down low that you had
a you had attempted a foot modeling
career I did it didn't pan out oh people
trying to buy feet picks yeah from me
yeah he said no one would buy your feet
picks I think you're confusing it with
bath water oh I'm just I'm recanting you
would sell feet picks for the right
price okay first of
all bath water 10,000 and you know it's
the I think this is the funniest part
like people sell bath water it's like a
cup or a
pint selling a gallon of bath water
which is first of all a shipping
nightmare second of all who wants like I
would the thing is I think a pint of
bath water is novel but then you think
of who's the type of person that wants a
gallon you know what I mean I don't
understand who's buying bath water no
one bought it no one bought no in
general who's buying anyone's bath water
only fans there's a lot of people in
this world Lord come quickly she you're
gonna love this amaranth we did a
podcast with her she said she made like
tens of thousands of dollars oh I
remember that selling her
farts just tell us what you think about
this I mean I don't feel good about it I
feel like it's I mean here's the thing
to me that's similar to selling an nft
it has as much value
truthfully I think it probably has
except it doesn't stink as much of an as
whoever bought that like they have
serious issues you think so serious
mental health issues what if it's $50
though any amount of money what if it's
like a couple bucks you wouldn't just if
someone gag that's fine but I still
think if like hey watch this but I think
anyone that does they're not doing okay
you know what I mean whoever is buying
no I would actually completely agree
with that I don't like having hard takes
on the podcast but I would agree with
that I think it's funny though it's yeah
if you did as a I just think whoever
bought that was not trying to be funny I
truly think they're not okay I think it
would be hilarious if you have a shelf
of like you know Awards stuff like that
you have just a glass jar like what's
that jar that it's amar's
fart how did we get here George how did
we get not as a podcast as a society
that's a good question I still sell the
bath water by the way 10 grand one
gallon bath water George you seem to be
disgusted by a lot of what goes on in
society today what do you think what do
you think are these biggest issues I
think we are too Bor I think we need
real problems the fact that this is what
we're all about is like we are we either
have too much disposable income or not
enough problems and so um I I don't
think we have our priority strike I
think we're all
honestly we're a little bit fatalist
there sort of like what is life what is
meaning I think we're going to have a
big sort of search for meaning as a
society like another Renaissance we're
too evolved as a species you think we're
too soft well I think we're just we have
everything we could ever want for and
more and now we're reverting to like we
all want to go camping to go see what
it's like to not have electricity for a
night you know what I mean like we are
circling all the way back to caveman era
because we have everything we could ever
want and so I I think we we are very
entitled as a culture as an American
people consumerist culture and uh you
know the fact that people are spending
money on on farts and only fans is proof
of that I do think that it is a
necessity for connection of existence to
face adversity in some way shape or form
to have some adversity and I think
that's getting getting harder and harder
to come by for a lot of people so a lot
of they'll tell you they have problems
as they you know tweet at it from their
$1,500 smartphone but are they problems
are they real problems to them it is I
mean everyone you know first world
problem is still a problem to that
person but you know people call into the
show and they're living with their
parents which is fine I'm not angry at
that but at some point like you need to
just get out and and pay some freaking
bills and have some work ethic and I
think we've gotten real comfortable as a
so a society with all these fallbacks
and we can just go into debt and live
whatever life we want at no cost to us
essentially but how would you solve that
issue because people are not going to
voluntarily make their life more
challenging no but I mean um uh Michael
Easter has an incredible book called The
Comfort crisis that I think everyone
should read where he kind of talks about
this very issue and we're just we've
gotten so comfortable we've all seen the
movie Wall-E we're sort of stepping into
that water where we're all just like
glaring at screens all day walking
through life we hate our jobs and we're
just finding ways to spend our money so
that we can feel something and to me
that's that's sad that we've gotten here
but it's where we are and so that's
where I think the Ramsey plan sort of
like kicks you into reality to like
force you to have some discipline and
sacrifice in your life I think is a
great thing because it causes personal
growth and it causes you to have control
in other areas of your life like your
physical health the amount of times
we've seen people who get out of debt
but then they their marriages get better
they're physically healthier is amazing
to me cuz I think transformation begets
transformation but how do you get
someone interested in doing that in the
first place if they're already
comfortable they got to want it you know
like what made you start working out
look better but you really had to want
it yeah CU you didn't look bad to begin
with but you had to get to a point where
like this is a priority for me and it's
a problem enough that I want to solve
I'm willing to do what it takes I'm
willing to go to the gym three times a
week same thing applies to finances I'm
willing to do that budget every single
month and actually stick to the plan
because I want to see the results but if
you look at data most people are
comfortable being being quote unquote
mediocre right like not going to the gym
they're comfortable with their payments
cuz they can afford the payments
therefore but it's been a change over
time and I don't think Human Nature has
changed so it must be something in the
external environment that's changed
correct well there's fear you know the
economy and the headlines and Co
definitely spooked a lot of people but
again I think it has to get to this
point where you're like this life ain't
it I deserve better I work too hard to
feel this broke that's the point you
have to get to to actually start
following the plan now it doesn't have
to get to that point Point I've just
found most people have to get to some
sort of Rock Bottom like this sucks
there's a better life I deserve better
for myself I'm going to go after it you
think it would be a detriment to the
economy if everyone got out of debt if
no one had debt what would happen a fun
hypothetical I truly think everything
would get better I know there's fear
because we have a debt-based economy and
some things would crash I'm totally
comfortable with all of the debt
companies crumbling to nothing if no one
took out debt right if everyone became
debt free then Capital One and American
Express and Sally May they all go to
crap Wells Fargo whatever all the
lending arms now people will still have
Banks uh but they're not going to make
as much money so they'll just be less
profitable they can't sponsor Taylor
Swift tours anymore we'll be okay but I
do think people would spend out of their
values more we might spend less as a
society but we'd spend on things that we
actually care about and the economy
would still be great we'd be supporting
more local businesses we'd just be
giving less money to lenders and giving
it more to people that really deserve it
that's my hot take I don't know if
that's true I'm not an economist but
that's my gut is that we'd all be
happier and spending on things we really
care about instead of flexing because
think about it every type of debt has
gone out of control because like look at
tuition the colleges were like we can
just raise tuition and people will just
keep taking out more debt cars we can
just raise the price of cars and people
will take out more car loans and so this
applies in every area of debt and it's
part of the reason we're at record
levels of every single type of debt debt
in America $17 trillion in Consumer Debt
alone yeah um and I think it's because
we have access to it yeah my worry would
be the economy would slow down to such a
huge extent that asset values would have
to fall stock prices would have to fall
and people might have to find an
alternative means of investing long term
because of that but companies would
still Prosper if we're spending money
we're still buying we're you know I have
more money now to spend on that Apple
product so Apple's going to do great I'm
going to spend money on this Tesla so
you're still supporting the company
you're cutting out the middleman of the
lenders and so the companies themselves
that I'm invested in most of them aren't
attached to debt well I guess in a way
you would have1 trillion dollar less of
spending throughout our economy because
that's what the credit card debt is just
credit Consumer Debt a trillion dollars
on top of that I don't know how many
trillions for Mortgage Debt how how much
money we're I talk about I think we're
at 12 M trillion in mortgages alone and
then auto loan debt so think 1.5 seven
or eight trillion across the board
without debt I think everything would
fall because how many people would be
able to buy a house outright there would
have to be payment plans in place sure
mortgages are the one you know we don't
yell at people are having a mortgage but
I think Consumer Debt is what's killing
us I don't think the everyday person is
dying because of the mortgage it's I
have all this debt plus this mortgage
that I really couldn't afford but I felt
like I had to get in the housing market
earlier rather than later because of
pressures or whatever and so I think
it's just compounding the problem but um
you know owning a house is a great to
wealth um I just think if you do it
right it'll be more of a blessing than a
burden do you think that now is a good
time to buy a
house yes if you're financially ready
now you know I still think I believe in
the economy and the US housing market
will continue to go up over time I don't
think houses are going to be
significantly cheaper in any point in
the future and history has proven that I
don't think there's going to be another
2008 fingers crossed because we've
solved a lot of the problems that caused
that um but I think when you have a you
have no debt a fully funded emergency
fund and a down payment you are
financially ready to buy a house so I
wouldn't try to time the market and wait
for the interest rates to move a certain
way I would go ahead and do that we say
you know date the rate marry the house
yeah you know what's interesting 84% of
people say that now is a bad time to buy
a house 84% is that because of prices
and interest rates yes okay interest
rates were the number one reason that
overtook home prices so it's because of
interest rates that that number is so
high you know the last time it was also
similarly High when's that 2010 wow
isn't that
interesting interesting so after the
housing crisis a lot of people also felt
now is a bad time to buy so it's very
interesting because I was having a
discussion with somebody best times to
buy looking back ex so I was having a
discussion with somebody the other day
and we're talking about how so many
people say now is a bad time to buy but
if you typically do the opposite of what
the mass seems to think is the better
option usually that is kind of works
like to me it's hard to wrap my mind
around it when I see home price is so
high mortgage is so high the cost of
renting so cheap relative to that but
you know when you look at what most
people are doing if you just do the
opposite in most cases you're better off
that's fascinating so it'll be very
interesting to see what happens over
these next 10 years if interest rates
come down I guess there's a chance yeah
everyone rushes into theet and you can
tell me this if interest rates go down
we're probably going to see a spike in
home prices yes and no the variable to
that is how many sellers sell so right
now we're seeing high home prices
because there's not a lot of inventory
because rates but if interest rates go
down to about 5% they're saying that's
the magic number where all of a sudden
if I have a three and a half% mortgage I
it doesn't hurt as much to give that up
for 5% but it does to 6% and so they're
saying 5% is the magic number that would
prompt more sellers to sell who were
thinking about selling who had those
handcuffs so there's a chance interest
rates come down buyers come in the
market but there's a lot of sell sellers
who say finally I could you know afford
to buy something else and not have to
worry about it I don't care about
getting giving up my 4% mortgage for 5%
it's not that big of a deal so maybe the
market gets flooded with inventory
there's also the theory that as that
flood comes in more sellers will say the
Market's going down I'm thinking about
selling in five years but let me sell it
now really quick before values go down
even further and my neighbors are
selling and let me be let yeah let me
beat him to it and I'll I'll price
myself a little lower than they are
there's a chance there's also a chance
people say I'm going to hold on to my
house and you know buyers have more
purchasing power and values go up it's
it's a total coin TOS I wish like there
there should be a way to to figure out
what's going to happen in this and like
run the numbers but I think the key is
like we're not going to see a crash
regardless of what your thumbnail said
but I know what you say in the video
it's not going to happen like the crash
is happening I'm like no it's not don't
lie to me so the shocking thing is that
like payments monthly payments are up
like 70% since 2020 now that is low in
terms of monthly payments but like when
you think 70% more those interest rates
I it definitely compounds that payment
and it hurts people and it makes it less
affordable but at what price at what
point does that impact prices I mean 70%
increase in monthly payments from those
who bought three years ago to today yeah
how much could do home prices have to
come down to balance things out if at
all only time will tell but I do feel
for people who want to be homeowners and
it's just feeling like more and more you
know just they're just so sad and
hopeless at this point because they need
a huge down payment and they're still
straddled with debt and so the only
thing you can do is try to get out of
debt get the emergency fund and build
that down payment as high as you can get
it to where you can then afford the
payment and what would you say to
someone who says I just want to rent I
have no problem with renting I think
renting is very wise which is another
hot take I know some people agree and
you'd probably be with me on this one
but renting is buying yourself patience
and I've seen people who did it the
other way they said well I told renting
is a waste of money I'm going to go buy
a house then they call the ramsy show
and they're like hey we're screwed this
mortgage payment is 65% of our take-home
pay and life happened and we don't know
what to do and now we're we're looking
to sell because we're in this bind and
so I'd rather you do it with patience
and buy it when you're ready even if the
price is higher the interest rates
whatever because when you do when you do
it and the mortgage payment is that much
your take-home pay you can't live the
rest of your life and so you have no
peace even though you're a homeowner
it's the American dream your life sucks
and so that's I we've just see too much
of the other side if when things don't
work out perfectly what are the most
disturbing calls you get on the ramsy
show oh my gosh I mean obviously there's
like the really sad ones um you know
addiction problems uh loved one passing
way too soon people co-signing and
getting into really murky
situations especially when it comes to
like Parent Plus Loans are real problem
where parents are now like hey my kids
stopped paying and now the loans on me
I'm trying to retire and I don't have
the money to pay this thing uh we're
seeing so many people underwater on car
loans it's almost every single call we
ask them and they're underwater on the
car loan by not by like a thousand but
by 10,000 so those are really sad as
well um and there's also the people who
have like lower incomes and we're
telling them hey like you're making $16
an hour like that's not going to cut it
you need to be go making 20 25 get some
education do whatever you have to do um
because they bar can pay the bills so
there's a lot of people hurting out
there and obviously we Ramsay show is
largely people with money problems you
know we get a few that are doing really
well they're like I have $3 million what
do I do with it and we're all like oh
boohoo you know send me a venmo but the
majority of people like life has
happened and they're in a predicament
they haven't prepared financially for it
and we're just trying to help them take
the right Next Step yeah and it's a
difficult thing to do in you know six
minutes of a of a call but our goal is
to give them a little bit of hope that's
all you can really do in six minutes is
give them hope and just a next step and
a partial plan and maybe we give them a
you know a product tool to help them
along is there anything that doesn't get
aired um in recent memory I don't think
we've ever like had to cut a call
sometimes if someone cusses we'll have
to hit the dump button is what it's
called where they cut the last 10
seconds so that's happened on occasion
but as far as something getting cut
completely I don't think that's happened
in a few years usually whatever is
screened and makes it to air it's then
live on radio it's live on you know it
goes to podcast pretty soon it's on
YouTube an hour later so everything's
pretty much out there do people ever
fake the calls like are there situations
like oh this this is not real there's
ones where people think we either like
planned a fake call which we never do
like sometimes we'll schedule a call if
someone emails us and we have it's a
great call we'll go and schedule it with
them but we don't like plan fake
situations for people to call in to
create great content but do they sneak
through occasionally we'll get the troll
here and there and uh the phone
screeners are amazing at sniffing that
out so to them for doing that but
sometimes they'll make it to air and
Dave's like that was a troll you know so
we've seen that a few times some of them
aren't as malicious as others some of
them are malicious where they're trying
to rile up Dave or whatever um what do
they say are they just like I'm trying
to think of some all this debt and I
just should I buy the Ferrari and yeah
some of them are just they want to they
want to argue with Dave about you know
one of his principles that's usually
what it is it's usually wanted to argue
with Dave and like it's some 18-year-old
that thinks he knows better than Dave
and he's like well Dave I don't
understand why wouldn't I take this
spread on the interest rate you know
those kinds of things we had a clip we
had a clip that went Mega viral you may
as well ask it now okay all right if you
could borrow a billion dollars at 0%
interest for 10 years would you do it
billion dollars 0% interest for 10 years
would I do
it no why I would be crushed under the
weight of trying to manage that well and
not lose it all it would be it would be
frightening and I know you're thinking
well just put it in a you know high
yield savings account and t- bills and
you'll make your money back so no and
this wild hypothetical scenario where I
could borrow a billion dollars at 0% I
just I wouldn't do it and that's part of
it is my values of like I just don't
borrow money and it's a principle that
like I live by so it it would go against
my own moral compass like I I wouldn't
be able to sleep at night and to me
that's not worth the spread I could make
now what if it's something smaller more
manageable 0 million interest free 10
years I me what's those
10,000 that wouldn't interest me I don't
think any amount I don't think it's an
amount to me I think I truly have such a
and it's not a uh it's not like well
you're you work for Dave Ramsey so of
course you're going to say that it truly
I've no it does it's not attractive to
me at all to take on any amount of debt
what if you could borrow a billion
dollars at negative 1% interest for 10
years that hurts my brain so you're
saying they're paying me
how it goes I think in like Venezuela or
something they have like is it Venezuela
there's a few countries with negative
interest rates I don't think Venezuela
is not one of them because um their
inflation is so high are they paying you
to take on you pay back less than you
borrow so let's just say you borrowed a
million doar you would pay back9
990,000 at the end of the term so would
you borrow a billion dollars attive 1% I
don't think a discounted loan is of any
interest to me no a billion dollar at 1%
I I think what what it is is it just you
have abundance already so
would saying they'll give you 10 I can
understand the take of like you have
abundance and acquiring more money just
for the sake of money is of no interest
to you I understand that and I think
that's the only argument that I could TR
don't know like what more money would do
for me cuz I don't have I mean you guys
are are doing very up your car there's
an just upgraded my wife's car and it's
the nicest car I've ever I've like holy
crap and I still am like okay like what
now you know what I mean like we can
upgrade an house and that's a dream of
ours to upgrade and pay cash for our
next house and have a bigger house for
fun but truly I'm like I don't know what
I would buy what experience I would take
that would add that much value to my
life like what item what experience I
don't I'm not going to retire what am I
going to you know not going to sit and
watch Netflix for the next 30 Years
there's no businesses I want to start I
like what I do I like the team I do that
with I'm paid very well for it so I'm
like I don't know charties you could
give that's true so if I could borrow a
billion at 0% invest that money give all
of the proceeds to charity I would
become a wonderful
philanthropist let's have that record
would you do it negative 1% interest and
you donate it all to charity do we get
have to really think through that I
would let someone else do it and I'd be
happy for them because there still is
like I
said still is weight it still is
something and you that I ow at the end
of the day regardless of what's
happening with that billion I owe
someone a billion dollars like that is
such an unfathomable you owe someone 900
and something million right now I have
it but if I invested let's say I don't
know I know T bills are probably the
safest bet right now or a high yield
savings account at 5% it still would
wait like I would be thinking about that
billion dollar every day you know what I
mean like there's not a day that goes by
that you're still not
thinking holy crap a billion dollars is
sitting out there you know what I mean
that's too much weight for me I truly
could not handle it I'll let someone
else you could pay it off early I'd pay
it off instantly and point is I don't
think he's going to do it what I
appreciate about I don't know I truly
now it's so hypothetical that it's
hilarious so it's like it's it's not
it's not meant to be a trap like I'm
worried a lot of people thought that
when I was asking Dave this question
that it was like supposed to be a trap I
just wanted to ask him because I thought
it would be imagine he said yes like I
do it absolutely you stupid I would love
to get another Ferrari yeah and I'm not
Dave like I never went bankrupt and
because I was overleveraged and the bank
called the notes like I never you know
my story is much more of the average
person going a little bit into Consumer
Debt 40 Grand paying it off and living a
better life on the other side what I
want to understand is Graham still and
we talked to Dr John delone about this
has this scarcity mentality when it
comes to a lot of different areas of his
life specifically financially and you
have this abundance mentality in the
exact same way that gr has a scarcity
mentality it bleeds into every other
part of your life and what I find really
interesting and I don't mean this in any
sort of like nag or dig or anything
Graham has a lot more money a whole lot
yet he still feels this scarcity and I
really respect and I just want to like
decode how you have this level of peace
and abundance in your life with such
less
money got paid off mortgage it's the
paid off mortgage but it can't just be
that it has to be something else
cuz what what is it that led you to
paying off that mortgage I well I think
if you really look at the emotional
underpinning of it it just comes down to
contentment like I know it's it's it's
that simple and it's that hard right to
be like I'm just content like I'm a very
anxious person naturally and so to
remove any level of you know pieces of
anxiety out of my life one of those
being debt has been really helpful to
give me a little bit of just peace and
so I think at the end of the day I'm
content with where I'm at and yes I have
still have goals and there's things that
I'd love to do but I don't have an
there's no end game there's nothing like
well once I get 5 million I'm retiring
and that's it now I hope to have 5
million one day in a retirement account
and we're able to retire and still have
a great income and go on Amazing trips
and all that but I have no endgame what
I've been trying to do as I get older is
just live in the present instead of
always going like well what's the next
thing because for too long I for the
last 10 years I've been doing that with
my career with my financial goals with
whatever it is and so I'm truly and it's
something I'm still working on this is
not like I've not mastered it I'm not
like some kind of Zen Yoda character I
just truly suck at living in the present
I'm always thinking about what's
happening tomorrow what's on the
schedule what are we going to do what
about that thing instead of just now
that I have a baby I think it changed
the way I view my time the way I view
money and like you stare into this
baby's eyes and like time just like
disappears like it doesn't matter
anymore when you're staring into that
baby's eyes so I think having a family
changes the mentality around that I'm
curious as you progress and you know you
have a family or you have kids or
whatever I wonder if that's going to
change that for you and if you have a
different set of goals and a different
lens I find it interesting but it feels
like it's exhausting because I'm like
there's no end like I don't know if I
could go start a business and make $100
million how would my life change would
it make it
worse maybe and I think that's something
a lot of people don't think about cuz
with more money and more responsibility
you know it changes things if you got
everything you wanted would you be
happier say that's the question at the
end of the day and what do we want I
don't think we really know as humans and
I I do think we've talked about this
before my faith is a big underpinning of
this that I think I'd be remiss to not
mention because I think it changes your
long-term view of Life of like what's
happening ahead when I die what has this
all been about you start thinking about
those big questions um what I want what
do I want people to say about me in my
funeral are they going to be like man
his YouTube videos were hilarious I
doubt it I think they're going to say he
was a great friend he was an amazing
husband he was a loving father that's
what they say and we joked about this on
your gravestone your Network's not going
to be like written on there and Graham's
like mine will I was like that's
actually a pretty baller move and I
respect the hustle there but it's like
what what is this all for like let's say
you go in the dirt what happens then
who' you leave your money to what impact
did you have did it make any did it make
any impact at all and so to me now I'm
like what is the ripple effect I want to
have well number one I want generational
wealth for my family I want my daughter
to inherit whatever Legacy we've built
up and nest egg and for her to manage
that wisely and for her to live a life
we can't imagine uh because of the work
that we did and the sacrifice we made I
want to be able to give to Charities and
pay for an adoption and buy single
parents cars and just do things that
like make my like we just gave 10 grand
to Waffle House employees in 3 hours and
to me that was the most fun I've had
with money in a long time way more than
buying my wife a new car way more than
paying off the house to see someone's
life change instantly because of
something I was able to do that was in
my control I'm like that's amazing to me
and so like the stuff Mr Beast is doing
of course like that's the stuff we're
going to be talking about generations to
come versus look at the Networth that he
amassed you know what I mean I like that
I like giving to people that are working
at at Waffle House and and I know that
sounds silly but I'm a big proponent of
like like I like to tip big that's kind
of my way of giving back I generally tip
higher percentages a lot higher than the
average person and I that's kind of like
I take a lot of Pride I think in that
and I love that because you have margin
yeah like if you were broke and you had
payments up to your eyeballs living a
lifestyle that you were trying to
maintain you wouldn't be able to give in
that way and so that's one of the
reasons that I want people to live
debt-free cuz you can't help but have
more margin to do those things when you
don't have payments to make what I find
interesting is you said that your
anxiety comes from you don't know what's
going to happen in the future and that's
the same thing Dr John deloney said and
that's the same thing I see in Graham
whenever he's explaining his financial
anxiety is like you don't know what
could happen to the market it could half
and then once it halfs you don't know
what could happen from there and you
don't know what could happen from there
it's never like like stuff that is
apocalyptic scenario do you ever have a
real fear that like the world could end
cuz at that point what are you going to
do no I don't I have a fear that our gr
stock market goes to zero no no let's
just say the worst case 1929 happen
something crazy like that let's just say
it's 50% well then you take 50% off
everything let's just say then how could
I live off that 50% okay I'll find a way
to live off the 50% now that's if you're
like at retirement age because if you
just hang on I also assume that my
income goes to zero I just like I'm
somewhat like incapacitated YouTube is
shut down or that I just choose voluntar
where I don't want to be forced to do
something so I take it in half how could
I live off the half I live off the half
and then I kind of think well I want a
bit of a buffer on top of that uh just
to give myself some flexibility in case
things get even worse so that's how I
kind of think of things I want to keep
the lifestyle without um having to worry
about if things drop by what lifestyle
because you're a pretty Frugal guy if
things like really got tight you would
be fine I'd find a way but I don't want
to downgrade it because it's like every
year I've increased My Lifestyle a
little bit like let's just say it's 5% a
year okay um but I do that purposely so
that I can sustain that sustain why
can't I say it's a hard one I want to be
able to challenging sustain that sort of
Lifestyle creep but I think purply do it
a little bit every year people making a
tenth of what you make spend more than
you do in a month yeah but just because
I want to be able to sustain that like
you know lifestyle creep and never have
to worry about it so yeah you could
spend way more you spend 100% but you
also you know how to make money like
that's I think a skill that will carry
you through any you know thick or thin I
like um not being forced yeah to do that
like anytime I feel forced to do
something I just don't like doing it for
whatever reason yeah I like doing things
that if I was like gram you have to make
these videos every week you like screw
you AB just having the freedom to say
you know if if I want to stop at any
point I can and that makes me very happy
yeah and again that kind of freedom I
think you have more options when you
have no
I could it I not I just feel like at the
end of the day I'm going to have L
stress about if things go downhill
having no debt yeah like a while ago I
got an offer to buy a part of my main
Channel and it was very enticing cuz cuz
the the valuation they were giving me on
the main channel was insane this is like
Shark Tank yeah it was uh 2021 though
and I knew that like this is the
cheapest money is ever going to be it
was a startup company that had a ton of
venture capital they were valuing it way
higher than ever thought it was but they
said that I'd have to create three
videos a week for the next 5 years oh
and that for me was killed it this
reminds me of like gen in Aladdin you
know where he's like he's forced he's
got the handcuffs when he's working for
jaar yeah it was just it was a minority
stake so it wouldn't change anything but
it was just like the output had to stay
the same yeah I know I just don't want
to be locked in and making three videos
a week for five years it's bad it's I
don't we all want options and freedom
and so we have different paths to get
there um but I just think mine has
proven over time to be a path anyone can
take and I think people can be I mean
you guys are successful you've done it
your way and I think a lot of your you
know your tribe and audience they'll do
it your way and they'll be okay like the
fact they're even watching this channel
tells me they're going to be okay um but
we just we talk to very different people
like the people we're talking to they're
going through things you know they're
not watching YouTube videos for fun
they're watching them because they need
help and so it's a very different
mindset and so I try to entertain and be
informative but at the end of the day
like there's people who need help and
therefore like I can argue about credit
card interest all day but there's a
single mom who's about to call in and be
like I just lost my husband I got three
kids do I do daycare what do I do and so
I'm like holy crap like there's real
problems in the world and this is a
luxury and privilege that we get to even
have these kinds of conversations that's
very true I think in my role it just you
have a very different perspective seeing
what people are really going through and
it it makes me more reverse to risk and
to debt cuz I've seen what it does to
people you know like Andre like he's
he's like I've seen my family struggle
with gambling addiction I'll never
gamble he's just it's not interesting to
him and the same uh happens with debt to
me I'm like I've seen too many people
hurt by debt why would I want to play
this game only to get bit by a snake
later on yeah what's the most surprising
thing that you've learned from Dave
Ramsey I think his his tenacity and grit
and perseverance is a inspiring like the
fact that this guy is still at it 30
years later with
more energy and um more passion than
ever before I'm like I want to be that
invested in whatever I'm doing and so he
keeps us on our toes but what I've
learned from him
there is that work is about more than
work like it's not a j o it's not
something where I'm just like I'm doing
it for the paycheck and one day you know
I'll call it quits like this dude is
going to keep going until he can't keep
going and he'll probably outlive me just
out of sure spite sheer spite um but his
passion around it has just really
inspired me to go like obviously that
thing for me is personal finance and I
didn't realize that until later on in my
life um but also the way he's leaving a
legacy like the way he's thinking so
future I mean he's been thinking about
personalities for a long time you guys
talked about this his succession plan
you joked about Dave Dave Ramsey's
retirement plan everyone's like no Dave
don't go I'm like he's not going
anywhere but it was a good title I'll
give you
that uh so it's just made me think more
big picture more long term and less
about like what am I doing what's my
thing and more what's everyone around me
how are they being affected by my life
and so that's a really interesting way
to to frame things up what's something
you think you can improve about your
personal finances oh man um I think my
investing my investing game now that you
know I'm at the place we're at like
getting into brokerage accounts and like
Mega back door and all of that stuff is
interesting to me and I'm not I'm not I
haven't dipped my toes in that water yet
um but but now that I'm there I think
investing is one area and I think
spending like we're doing fine but I
think there's still ways that we've
gotten lazy a little bit in kind of how
we've been spending and getting that
budget just tightened back up uh now
that we have a baby girl it's just like
there's new expenses in our world and so
we we need to readjust for some of that
and also like being more open I think my
generosity muscle needs some flexing
because we were so like we have these
goals we got to pay off this house we're
going to get upgrade the car and now
that have more freedom it's like what
are the Strategic ways we're going to
give and spontaneously planned um all
kinds of ways and so that's something I
need to get better at and seeing Dave
and the way they've done that with the
family Foundation uh is really cool have
you ever given and been unimpressed by
somebody's reaction oh man you know
that's it's such a hard thing when you
give because you're hoping like
selfishly you're like I hope this is a
moment and sometimes it's not um we we
paid off uh $10 million of debt so Dave
bought the book of debt from this
company for out 250 Grand and it was 10
million worth oh so we got to make a
debt collection and so uh he bought $10
million worth of debt for 250 Grand and
then we got to make the calls all the
Ramsey team members made calls to let
the people know hey your debt has been
paid off and I remember we called I
called this guy and I was like hey uh
this is George from Ramsey Solutions
just want to let you know that car that
you had in collections this you know
Nissan Mac
has been paid off
completely and he said I didn't ask you
to do that I was like oh my gosh this
backfired this backfired what do I say
he was upset why it's in collection I
don't know well the truth is these
people haven't paid on this debt in a
long time they don't maybe don't care
about it anymore they've moved on but I
was just so taken aback like if that was
me I'd be like are you serious yeah oh
my gosh like thank you so much and so
that was just like you don't know what
you're going to get on the other side of
generosity so that was a a little lesson
I learned there of like you know set
your expectations it could go south what
I've been doing is getting people's
dinners so sometimes we'll go out I'll
just see like a couple or you know you
got my dinner I won't get Jack's dinner
Jack do but right I'll see random people
or there's there's one this guy kind of
sat alone an older guy and I was like
you know I'm just getting his dinner but
I'll just tell the people secretly I'll
pay for it he doesn't know it's me no
one knows it's me uh he just knows
someone has paid for your someone's paid
for your bill usually after we've left
uh and their bill is paid for but I
remember one time we went to a
restaurant and we're sitting down and we
saw this lady come in and she had a
young child with her and it was maybe
like 9900 p.m. and I'm thinking is she
waiting for something is it pick up and
then I realized she's doing the delivery
service and I thought like it's got to
be maybe like a single mom because
obviously if like someone's at home the
kid wouldn't be out with her and the kid
looks like young like a young kid like
four or 5 years old is kind of sitting
and like the mom's obviously doing this
and and so I give her $100 and I say hey
I just want to give you this and I don't
want to say I was unimpressed by your
reaction was like oh thanks but that you
were hoping for a little bit more I was
hoping for a little more but anyway you
know you got to do it because you like
doing it but uh the reaction would would
have been nice yeah now that that's a
tough part I mean you always hoping and
we got some of that when I gave uh the
10 grand at Waffle House at three
different locations uh we paid for
everyone's tab the shocking part is you
could go into any Waffle House in
America and cover the tab of the entire
a restaurant for $100 like that that was
mindboggling you know made 150 bucks for
a packed restaurant like that is such a
cool thing to do just walk in and be
like hey everyone here 200 bucks
whatever anyone's tab is I'm covering it
and here's a $50 tip to the waitress
that's just a cool fun thing to do and
it's not a waffle I mean you can go to
any place but for some reason you know
talking to the people at Waffle House
like this lady had been shot in the
chest by her kid's dad who's clearly not
in their life anymore single mom of
three kids she'll be working on
Christmas Day and so when I gave her 500
bucks I mean she was already in tears
and then I said hey you know what what
are you getting the kids for Christmas
she's like I don't know I'm working on
Christmas Day and I was like I want
these kids to have an amazing Christmas
here's an extra $2,000 wow and the
floodgates open the co-workers are all
hugging her and it wasn't like a flex on
my part it wasn't even my money you know
it was it was Ramsay's money and we just
wanted to find a fun way to be generous
and I thought let's go to Waffle House
but like that to me that changed that
affected me more than her potentially
you know what I mean like I'll never
forget that of just the power of you
know 2,000 bucks that's still a lot of
money um but it changes her world you
know what I mean and so whatever we
think is a lot of money to someone else
or we don't think is a lot of money to
someone else is life changing whether
it's in another country or whatever I
like that over Charities because you get
to see the impact firsthand and I feel
like sometimes you you give to a charity
and it's more just like you know you get
these things in the mail every now
thanks for your you get to see yeah you
get to I like to see the impact it makes
on people firstand also you do not know
how efficient Charities are what they're
spending oh I don't know how efficent
they are that they spend a lot of money
on Market you know's really cool and one
other thing I gave to a few different
charities earlier this year and ever
since then for the past like six months
oh you getting bombarded every single
time I open the the mailbox they text me
my emails it's like y I gave you a good
chunk of change it's like every single
are the animal ones oh they that is
never ending and they send you photos
thank you for your puppy in the mail
what are you trying to do to me you know
whatever whatever it is I did that at
Petco and I signed up for one of those
things and have you guys heard of
Charity water mm uh it's run by a guy
named Scott Harrison and he has
revolutionized charity because here's
what he did he said hey I'm going to
change the game 100% of your donation
goes to fund water projects in Africa
and so you're wondering well how does
they cover overhead and bills and all
that they cover that with private donors
so a group of private donors comes
together to cover salary overhead all of
that and 100% of donations wow go
straight to the project and they even
have found a way to track your donation
to the exact water project and they will
follow up awesome that's fantastic you
can go in online and see the exact
location of your water project the
status of it and the people affected by
it sharing their stories and to me that
is like what every charity in America
needs to get to so I love that model of
private donors cover salary and overhead
and consumer donations Go 100% yeah
because that's the kind of transparency
that will cause more people to give cuz
there's there's a clear distrust and
there's like sites like charity
navigator that help with this which is
cool but I think that's a really cool
model I have a question now don't feel
like you need to answer this question I
don't know if it like will cause any
tension or anything I just won't answer
if I don't want to Yeah by all means we
can cut it out um but Dave is not my
dad dang it man everyone everyone wanted
Wonder no Dave was Under Fire recently
for 8% withdrawal rate what do you think
about that do you think 8% withdrawal
rate is fine you think that that could
be a good Benchmark for people when
they're trying to retire um I think
there's certain situations where that
would be totally fine if you follow the
Ramsey plan and you have a giant nest
egg and that's your plan um then that's
sustainable if you look at real numbers
hypothetically like this is all it's
like your billion dollar question would
you would you get a billion dollars and
do this the realistic numbers are if you
had $2 million in retirement and you
withdrawing 8% um you would be okay with
a paid for house money in the bank you
know and you would adjust and Dave said
on the show with Rachel Rachel was like
well hey what if the return that year
was 10% instead of 12 he go well you
could take it down take it down to 6%
but the key here is being flexible with
your spending in retirement so in
retirement if you're going I need 12
Grand to to sustain this or else it's
all going to fall apart you've already
failed you need to have a lot of margin
for error in retirement um and that's
why we tell people like invest 15% as
soon as you're out of debt once you have
the house paid off invest way more max
out retirement accounts so the amount of
people who are actually having to live
this out is probably slim to none the
argument of 4% or 6% or 8% um and
there's there's a lot of studies that
show because all of this is based on uh
the Monte Carlos simulation the Trinity
study Trinity study Monte Carlos situ
sitation and so a lot of them showed you
could have negative money in retirement
you could have way more than you ever
imagined in retir it's the failure rate
of Dave Ramsey's % over 48% or 60%
failure rate it was yeah it was it a
point yeah it was over a 30-year time
frame but there was a high failure rate
and it's like do you want to give that
to a 50/50 coin flip of failing that
assuming you keep your expenses at 8%
adjusted for inflation every year
beginning the first year the other thing
is that if you have a few bad years
initially it's almost 100% SE of risk
return is what you're talking yeah sure
and I I think realistically people
adjust lifestyle depending on market
conditions and so that's why I think
what Dave was saying was there's a lot
of Hope Stealers out there who are like
if you don't have $2 million you're
screwed because you have to do 4% if you
don't do that you're screwed what Dave's
saying is you're going to be okay if you
have no debt and a million2 million $3
million in retirement you're going to
have a fine life and you can withdraw
more than 4% did did Dave talk to you at
all about this after the call because it
seemed like he said if George said
something like that we're going to take
the video down oh yeah well the producer
talked to him he was like Hey the caller
took that out of context maliciously
here's what George actually said and
they was like oh okay cool and moved on
with this day but no there was no we
didn't it crazy on Twitter because we
know this the financial Community blew
up over this the day before posting our
Dave Ramsey video this blew up on
Twitter and I was I was texting Jack I'm
like dude you see this stuff going down
on on Twitter million tens of millions
of views everyone was posting memes of
like Dave Ramsey with like Lambos and
this luxury lifestyle like withdrawing
8% that's hilar hilarious well the
financial Community for a long time has
loved to use Dave as a punching bag for
clicks and views we all we all know that
um and at the same at the in in the same
clip Dave has helped millions of people
and these people are in their mom's
basement with their you know they just
became financial advisers and they have
an opinion and they've helped almost
nobody and so I get why they're railing
against it and their job is to you know
be financial advisers and do whatever
the financial Community does but um I I
think it's such a funny hypothetical
situation or argument and so nerdy that
I'm like I again it's a wonderful
argument to have the fact is people
aren't saving for retirement so whether
we're going to argue about four or six
or 8% is a silly thing when I'm like
people aren't even investing is there
anything you disagree with Dave about
I'm trying to think like obviously we
agree on on our anti- debt stance we
agree on the investing stance and he's
he's cool in index funds as well he
invests in index funds in a brokerage
account when he gets like a bonus check
U but we have the same investing
strategy philosophy we're probably
invested in the same funds in 401K I'm
probably more like on the millennial
side I'm probably just into things that
he may not be into um one being Teslas
he's a he's a Tesla hater unfortunately
but that's not really a financial he
still would probably say it was a bad
financial decision that Rachel and I
drive Teslas um but as far as
spending goes I don't think he would we
have much to disagree on I mean and it's
not even like I'm towing the company
line of like I have to agree with daveon
everything I fully agree with the baby
steps um and we talk we've you know went
back and forth about baby step one a,
emergency fund and dead Avalanche vers
snowball and what is in a a full
emergency fund and what's the best way
to invest but truly like I've lived out
his principles and they worked and so
like I only have good things to say um
not only because of my experience but
millions of others that have come before
me and after me do you have any advice
for Dave Ramsey uh don't let the trolls
get to you Dave do they well I think uh
like he he'll get riled up you know on
air and I have more patience with the
like 20-year-old who wants to argue
about the nerdy stuff and I think at
this point he's just like I got people
to help man why are you clogging up my
phone lines wanting to argue about this
thing you know what I mean I don't think
Dave needs any of my advice I think he's
doing great he's he's living his values
out beautifully he just went to Egypt
for like two weeks with his wife an
amazing trip he spent that 8% he he
spent he spent a good healthy chunk of
money so that's the cool thing about
Dave is he's so balanced when it comes
to spending saving and giving like he we
would call that a flat tire he's great
at spending money he's great at resting
like when he's not at work the dude is
at The Lakehouse he's enjoying himself
in Cabo he's living a great life he's
saving plenty of money he's investing
wisely for the future and he's also
giving outrageously I mean to in ways
that Boggle my mind and so I don't have
any advice for Dave other than um maybe
I'm trying to think like on the
millennial side of things I'd be like
come on Dave like loosen up on this
thing I'm trying to think generationally
CU you know we get a bad rap Millennials
gen Z but even Dave is quick to say like
there's people there's gen zers that
suck there's gen zers that are awesome
and we see a lot of both um but I think
he can give them the redddit community a
bad rap for one you know Twitter commun
cuz he only gets the trolls and so in
his mind only Trolls Exist on those
platforms but sometimes um you know I
appreciate the honesty of the people on
there you know saying their truth but
he's uh he's quick to block them as well
if you could draw a pie of your net
worth and where your money is allocated
what would it look like okay I'm going
to be really boring and you're not
you're going to disagree with it but
this is my true life um because of the
housing market and our paid for house
and how how we over indexed on that
that's probably that's 3/4 of of our net
worth is our paid for house the other
mostly that quarter is going to be our
401 case our Roth we both have Roth
401ks um I probably have double what my
wife does because of I've worked longer
at ramsy I've made more money and so
because of that the allocation of my 15%
was just higher so that's pretty much it
other than that we have our our cars are
very small piece of our net worth our
savings account and checking account are
a very small part of our net worth
majority probably 90 5% is house in
401ks and I have a small Ira with about
six grand from a rollover from when I
worked at Apple that's it it's that Bor
I have no crypto no single stocks no
real estate property other than my
primary
home I want to onew answer to this okay
okay do you think Graham and Macy should
have joint accounts gosh does it just
have to be a yes or no one word answer
yes Graham one word answer they're now
this is caveat once they're
married okay once they're married not a
second sooner right and not a second
later I mean they can go on the
honeymoon on the alar but as soon as
they're back from the honeymoon let's
combine the I think we have a joint two
separates the his and hers his and hers
with one
joint why what is the benefit to Macy
and what's the benefit to you I think
mostly the benefits to me I mean when
you look at it objectively but honestly
but I think it is I think it's perfectly
fair but a lot of it but a lot of it is
in like you know certain accounts and
and investment brokerages that it just
makes sense it shouldn't necessarily be
a joint account it's not be the harm in
saying here's our joint checking this is
where we spend all of our money and you
have a line item of hey Macy you can
spend 500 bucks on whatever you want
graham gets 500 bucks because she's able
to do that anyway in her personal
account so what's the difference if it's
all joint well that's the the joint
account shared expenses go from that so
we still have a joint account so she can
still do that from the joint account but
she has her money that she could spend
however she wants I will never question
that but it's not our money the the
joint account is let's say you guys have
a kid she decides to stay home what
happens well I already pay all the
expenses so it's you know everything for
her she could spend it if she wants to
everything yeah she could spend 10 grand
a month how yeah she if she if she makes
her money she decides she wants to if
she makes her money I said if she stayed
home with a kid she has no traditional
income now mhm and what's your take on
this Jack do you think they should do
what do I think
they realistically like I think you want
you go first no I'm just I've only seen
it where separate accounts has caused
more marital Strife than it caused any
blessing I've rarely seen it and when it
does cause any blessing it's because
they brushed under the rug and they're
like well we just don't talk about it
it's he does his thing I do my thing we
have the shared account and I'm like
you're living like roommates like you're
like if you're venmoing if you're if
you're married and you're sending each
other venos you're doing it wrong
that's not a marriage like marriage is
we are becoming one in every way shape
and form we're sharing a bed we're
sharing DNA we're making babies but we
can't share a bank account that's insane
so two things um if I were in Graham's
position this is if a big if I'd
probably want separate accounts that's
just me saying what but but I think that
this is a really tough line to kind of
tow um but I also think that
like if it's me actually me I also at
the same time I I understand like having
joint because if you just split it 50/50
with Graham's amount of money I'd still
be fine you know what I mean I ne I know
I'll never need the amount of money I
don't even think I like would
necessarily love to have one I don't
think it would improve my life to have
the amount of money that Graham
currently has let alone half you know
don't ever give him a raise he said he's
fine and you know I tried to neate with
Jack and he just he wants more D aain he
says one thing but he does other want to
make less have to I don't have half of
the amount of money you have sure right
so I think that there is a difference
there but that's besides the point um I
think i' would be okay splitting it
because I know I'd be fine with hat but
it would be extremely hard to part with
that money that's obviously worst case
scenario I don't even think that should
be in question uh relative to the
sadness of splitting with a partner that
you're going supposed to spend the rest
of your life with but um I don't know I
think like for me and my State I'd
probably be fine joint but then again
like I'm not Graham I don't have the
amount of money Graham has so I think
it's also it's different you know what I
mean that's fair and also like the money
isn't necessarily something that you're
like like you're putting a value on the
relationship it's just like hey I worked
extremely hard for this and this is
something that I just prefer to keep to
myself like there are secrets sure that
people will go into marriage with it's
inevitable you can say oh you should
talk about everything you don't right
there are certain things that you'll
just hold to yourself till the day you
die and um that's totally fun and people
are different and if someone has
different value and if it works for a
certain couple and it works you could
look you could look at statistics and
all available data and say oh it
generally doesn't work but I think that
there are also going to be exceptions to
the statistics oh sure yeah it's not
saying that Graham and Macy won't have a
long healthy happy marriage I just think
there's there's less of a chance less
risk of you know Financial infidelity as
we call it where there's a lack of
transparency and I didn't know and
there's resentment building up um
because again if she stays home or has a
much lower income and it's now unfair
because Graham makes this that it just
causes more awkwardness in the
relationship I understand I think that's
where the transparency comes in and I
think that's like the key to it all is
being completely honest with each other
so in my current life I probably would
have joint accounts but I actually this
is one of the few things where I
understand the way that Graham's brain
works that's fair very few things I'm
like why do you think the way that you
do and this when you guys were on my
YouTube Channel people love the
relationship talk and uh they also
thought Jack was a very eligible
bachelor YouTube comment find someone
from having day seriously that was a
good good ha you know what I did a blow
dryer you did a blow dryer I did he use
my strategy do a blow dryer you didn't I
told you the blow I used it that day I
used it that day and I think it's time I
told you I was going to I was going to
give you a little qua to see what it
looks like up there no unwilling I'm
unwilling and you know what's hilarious
I used a blow dryer on the podcast we
did with Dr John deloney worst hair I've
ever had you got to learn how to use
something yeah something Str you know
we're going to get this thing dialed in
where every day it's super consistent
yeah I would buy a course if you could
maybe craft that's my new course it's
not going to be about money it's about
how to care for your hair right how much
would you pay for your course yeah more
than you'd pay for a gallon of Grahams
bath water hopefully do you accept
credit because then I'd probably pay a
little bit more crypto take crypto if
you donated crypto for the course I
would take it 20 bucks that way I I
never bought crypto I was donated crypto
from Jack there we go I like that a
hairstyle you had that was similar to
mine remember that you got a haircut
that was like very s he just wants me
slowly over time to change into to morph
into Grand he wants me to actually
changeed my name to Graham step well
between your hair and then Graham's
workout routine where he just exploded I
was like I don't know what's going on
with you guys like did you work with
I've regressed a little bit
unfortunately oh no food poisoning I
just not been to the gym as much wow
yeah it's been like a week are you doing
okay now yeah I'm fine now you're just
shriveling away before our eyes I've
done five pounds Believe It or Not dang
yeah but yeah yeah so the the downside
of those 5 lbs uh half of that is muscle
yeah yeah that's so I've lost 2 and half
PBS of muscle two and A2 pounds of f not
working out I stay the same consistently
got eat more 10 years in yeah what can I
say all right cool I think that's good
is there any other we should discuss
anything we're Miss I mean I don't know
if we have any other arguments I mean
there's a lot more to unpack from this
but that's for another time another day
but if uh if people do want to check it
out they can do that at ramsy
solutions.com store check out Breaking
Free from broke wherever Brook are sold
I'm really proud of it the audiobook is
like a whole produced thing so if
they're listening before January 16th I
don't know that they will we might post
this sooner and let me they'll get all
the pre-order bonuses for free like
audiobook ebook all that let me also say
this I belly laughed several times you
did yes I Tri to make it really funny it
sounds exactly like you a lot of the yes
like I will I will read it and hear your
voice as I'm reading that means the
world and it's hilarious and a lot of
the times people will make books and it
just sounds nothing like them could be a
ghost riter sounds exactly like you
there's no way a ghost writer could have
written this because it is it is my
jokes whether good or bad you can tell
they are mine and so I did try really
hard to make a money book that was
conversational funny well researched
that could help anybody and uh while
being true to myself and true to Ramsey
so I'm really proud of it the team's
done an amazing job I mean God bless I
feel bad for people who are doing this
on their own like authors that are doing
this on their own is it's so much work
and so even though I wrote the book uh
took a billion people to make this
happen and uh I'm really excited about
it it's it's selling really well people
are excited to read it and uh the audio
book is going to be fire so if you like
to listen this is this is the one for
you I like to read books while listening
to the audiobook do you guys do that
listen to three books I read the book
while the audio is piped into my ears
because that's how the level of like add
that I have so helps me Focus there are
studies that show that you actually
retain more knowledge when you're
reading when you're doing that thank you
for that I knew you had a study were you
having a good hair day that day um you
know I think I was I was nervous about
photo shoot day you're always scared
about like what is my how did I sleep
what does my face look like the team did
not do me any favors and they didn't
give me like a tan and post yeah the
only thing I was uh going to say I would
up the saturation it seems like you are
too white like too pale well to be fair
against that bright orange I think
anything would be better little corner
right there on your forehead yeah yeah
it's a little too like you're getting a
solid extra inch on the hair though they
could have photoshopped that a little
higher the hair I'm going to talk to our
design guys they did whiten my shoes a
little bit help they whiten my shoes
print it on like five copies where the
hair goes behind the T full Jimmy
Neutron yeah yeah that would be the back
folds no truthfully you know it's not
Photoshop because I would have made them
make me taller in post you can tell I'm
small on the cover which is sad I think
you look you know but you know I think
we did they did it they polished a tur
on this one I think they did a great job
with the cover it's gorgeous and uh I
hope just wanted to stand out like in
all the noise in the financial world
that's the whole point of this is to
stand out in the crowd and swim upstream
so I hope I hope this book pisses a lot
of people off into Breaking Free from
certainly it pissed me
off done I tell I say this is going to
be jarring this is not going to be what
you want to hear it's it's sort of like
you're you're it's the vegan documentary
they're like here's how they actually
make the meat you're like oh gosh that's
what I wanted for debt okay and I think
it did that perfect well thank you so
much for coming on we'll link to your
information Down Below in the
description thank you for making it to
Vegas we'll see you in Nashville it's an
honor and make sure to just slam that
subscribe who's not subscribed to this
guys we're racing Caleb Hammer to a
million subscribers if you could please
million before Caleb he's like 20K ahead
of us is he actually he's like 15 maybe
20K we need subscribers I think we need
a new hashtag so we got to beat Caleb 2
million if you're not subscribed I think
it's like 50% of people watching or
higher with the shorts are com we can be
Caleb I think three of us equals at
least one Caleb cool cool oh and they
say yeah thumbnail oh what's come on in
oh my goodness we have a bit of a
surprise for you now this was completely
unpl this man this man is going to give
you the best Ste you've ever had guess
how much this box is
worth oh my gosh uh based on The
Branding alone yeah and the weight I'm
going to go $175 you're actually spot on
are you serious $25 off what is in this
open the box open the box so nervous
this is pretty much the ultimate Las
Vegas
Flex look at that oh my
gosh look at what's in here oh come on
that looks so good this was freshly made
in the kitchen 10 minutes ago how is
this getting the freshest possible
sandwich that you could ever eat and
it's right here with by the way the best
quality meat this is not sponsored what
kind of correct me if I'm saying this
wrong it's Japanese Miyazaki aab A5 wagu
A5 wag it's made in Sandwich this is
$200 in this tiny box to what do we owe
this pleasure okay so basically these
guys reached out to us on Instagram and
they're like hey we'd love to bring you
a sandwich and film a little video for
it we tried the sandwich it was insane
how so good and that was yesterday and
we're like Hey we're actually shooting
with George come back tomorrow and we
could show it on our podcast so yeah
it's a little bonus clip for you guys I
don't deserve this expensive sandwich
not we figured it's like a guy you would
appreciate this a lot uh eat it okay I
want to watch you eat it if you guys are
in Vegas and you guys want to try this
out it's all going to be linked down
below definitely try it out all right
can we do the same time not sponsored
all they just brought this is just a
cool concept and we really like it Che
that's it cheers
cheers touch meat all right there we go
yeah now that you say it that way it
feels different I'm going I'm
gluten-free can I just take a bite of
the uh the steak is that okay with you
guys does the steak have gluten in it
it's fine that's fine oh my gosh is that
incredible that's probably the best
steak you've ever had that cow was a
better life than I lived it's so good it
is so tender I've never had steak that
melts in your mouth say hi to all the
vegetarians I'm sorry but you're wrong
like if you think the Lord didn't intend
for us to eat this you're just
wrong oh my go I got to hang out with
you guys more often I told
you do you want a piece of this meat
stick Sarah oh my gosh sure I'll try
it